all right good morning good morning good
morning people of the internets hello
and welcome to Harry
Potter to Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows part one
we're doing it we're doing it here today
ladies and
gentlemen if this is your first time
joining us thank you so much for
stopping by we do a little just chatting
segment here in the beginning if you're
watching this in the replay Squad thank
you for checking it out you can go down
to the time stamps below and if you want
to just jump straight to the game play
I'll have that in there but for those of
you who are here live or those of you
who watching on the replay and want to
see this little just chatting segment at
the beginning welcome in good morning
everyone good morning Tri wizard Tuesday
is back catching you guys up from if you
were here last time we did finish off
the
Platinum we did finish it off in Half
Blood Prince we found the final Crest
that we were
missing and shared that in a little uh
Members Only video that we that we
posted
so oh man I don't think I need this
giant blanket although it is pretty cold
today but wow lots of
static lots of
static the worst game of all Derek oh
man that's what I've heard that's what
I've heard Sheena yes it's a game this
this game right here this little gy of a
game now what's really crazy is
that Half Blood Prince was so
good half BL Prince was was was amazing
and then this game was released I'm
trying to see the date on it here if it
has a date cuz when did Deathly
Hallows 2010 I mean
so they should have been able to take
everything that they had learned from
Order of the Phoenix oh no here goes
I got to stop doing that guys my camera
has
this it detects these hand
gestures and so whenever I do that it
tells the camera hey you want you want
to start tracking right so then it
starts like following me all around the
screen all right I I'm like Allan too I
love I love talking with my hands but
just I guess I could just be more like
this instead of like that
oh my goodness sorry about the little uh
the little delay
guys um I was going to start around 9:30
this morning but my wife and I decided
to take a little morning walk she's off
work today so always like to try and get
in a little a little walk in the morning
walked around the neighborhood it's
freezing
cold but yeah so I thought let me push
it back about 15
minutes it's official Hogwarts like he's
now number one
it passed tears of the king wait didn't
we already know that didn't we know that
uh I thought they had already said that
Hogwarts was uh I know WB had said it
but we didn't have like official Zelda
numbers yet did they do we finally have
official Zelda numbers for 2023 is that
what you're saying Christian gamer
because I know a lot of people kept
saying I bet Zelda out sold it or I bet
balers gate out sold it which like if it
did that's
fine but people keep saying that I'm
like Source do you do you have a source
for the balers gate thing no nobody ever
has a
source I'm like don't you think if
balers gate was the bestselling Game of
the Year wouldn't they want to to tell
people that same thing for Zelda
wouldn't they want that out there the
weird thing about Nintendo is they in
the uh in the little
report it used to be called NPD it's
called something different now but
Nintendo doesn't report digital sales
which on a console like the switch you
got to think there's a ton of digital
sales so tears of the kingdom was pretty
high even without the digital sales yeah
I mean regardless even if an if if a
game did outsell Hogwarts Legacy like it
was one of the best selling already one
of the best selling games ever I mean
it's like starting to crack top 100 list
you know of of all time it's just an
incredible thing that they did Dylan
welcome in dude caric it's it's been a
long time since I've come to Retro live
stream great to be here great to have
you here caric welcome back Arvin how's
it going welcome in Arvin kisi good
morning good
morning Marco is back with us Marco
welcome in dude military man love the
movie and book yeah the book the book
especially such a great end to the
series such a great
end GG is a lobster is back as well GG
welcome in Dylan make sure to hit that
like button yes guys appreciate it
appreciate
it Sheena it's a game oh yeah we
answered that yeah it is in fact they
were trying to make a
game they were they were trying
to Derek good morning my friend welcome
Anna how's it going good to see you King
Tut welcome in there Jared is back and
Satish Z is back Marcus is here with us
again bill is here with us good morning
Bill although I think it's like really
late for
you Bill I did see
that I did see that about the trophies
you guys know regulars of the stream
know I'm a I'm a big Trophy Hunter I
love going after the
trophies but for this game now it's a
shorter game they say that the story if
you only like rush through and do story
it's about five
hours but if you want the platinum
trophy in this
game you have to beat it on the hard
difficulty
you have to beat it on the medium
difficulty and you have to beat it on
the easy difficulty three playthroughs
minimum required No No Way Around It can
you believe
that three playthroughs so I've not
committed to it yet Bill I'm going to
wait and
see how bad it
is I mean as long as it's like
playable and as long as I'm not like
getting any
major annoying bugs glitches that kind
of thing I might do
it because I I think it'd be pretty cool
to say I have every Harry Potter
platinum trophy ever made I don't know
about you guys you guys are like no I I
don't a lot of people don't care about
trophies I get it but me I love them man
those little those little digital Badges
of Honor that says you you retro
rour you played this horrible game for
three playthroughs I won it man so we'll
see we'll see if I go for
it
uh oh Derek wait hold on so I have never
never been a fan of streaming games
found your channel you're hooking now
Derek dude well we try to we do things a
little bit different around here if you
H haven't been able to tell already
we keep things pretty laid-back pretty
familyfriendly I get a little
competitive
sometimes man I just love I love the
challenge I love the challenge Dylan is
back good morning Dylan how's it going
Anna can't you disable yeah see that's
what I do I disable the hand gestures
but then to turn it back on it's like
the hand holding
up like can I not just
can I not just okay hold on let me look
there is a setting in here I've turned
this off before and then it keeps coming
back on I think it like Auto detects
when I hold up my hand but yeah let me
just turn that off
again hold on let me try it now let me
try
it I think we might have fixed it I bet
the last time I updated the software it
probably like reset to the default but
yeah good call hopefully cuz yeah I used
to not have to worry about it hopefully
that'll fix it call of Potter yeah I've
heard a lot of people refer to as that
Ryan De La Cruz in the house welcome in
Ryan kick rocks how's it going good
morning Metatron good morning Wookie
cookie good morning or good afternoon
that's right we got a worldwide audience
here people joining in from around the
world oh gotcha Christian gamer so it's
for worldwide before it was just in the
US
interesting very cool I don't know if
Legacy reported that
or
I'm looking through here see if I see
any announcements this morning haven't
really been on been on the socials yet
today Oscar how's it going good night
for
Oscar gotcha oh yeah probably won't let
you uh post the link Christian gamer but
Dy looks like Dylan's already helping
you out trying to get it
here this may be a platinum that you
won't go for I know
right
right we'll see man we'll see like if
it's oh dude that's a good point Dylan
like it might be so bad that you guys
don't think I can do
it and if I see it as oh o o if I see it
as a
challenge all bets are off
man all there you see Anna Anna's got me
me figured out Han's got me figured out
if we keep saying he won't go for the
Platinum will reto actually go for
the that's me I'm the guy who people
like anytime you're like you can't do
that I'm like oh great well I'm going to
be here for the next five hours
now trying to prove you wrong I may not
succeed but I'm going to give it one
heck of an effort that's for
sure that is for sure Jenny good morning
welcome
in Mrs rakor is here here as well good
morning already said hello to you
today Anthony's
Galactic good Morning Anthony how's it
going
dude and I missed somebody baggy boo
there it is I knew I saw somebody else
in
there I knew I saw someone else all
right hold on let me make sure I got
everybody B Mill one of your goals
Platinum every Harry Potter I know I
think that would be cool as a teenager
you couldn't get past the first part of
this game oh boy oh
boy oh
boy Wario good morning what's
up you only have a tiny tiny retro at
the corner of your screen Anna the fact
that you have any retro at all is
appreciated now just picturing like a
tiny little
box need to do like a little squeaky
voice to go with the Tiny Box over
there watch
you yeah challenge
accepted house okay I did yeah I saw
your comment on the members only video
so you were asking about just Harry
Potter favorite Harry Potter book and
movie book's easy it's it's Deathly
Hallows but movie I go I go back and
forth man because I I have problems with
each of
them they are components that I critique
from each
one like the most book
accurate it's probably the first one
it's the most book
accurate um the best balance of like
book stuff but also putting your own
spin on it in the
movie probably prisoner
baban and then although the last ones
were all very well made like all the
basically the david8 ones so david8
started directing at Order of the
Phoenix did Half Blood prins and did
both Deathly
Hallows there's just something off about
all of them I don't know what it is like
as far as like the technical aspects the
effects and everything obviously were
great at that point the acting at that
point is really really
solid but there's like a a spirit that's
just missing in those I see I watched a
video on this a few years back on
YouTube that was like really diving in
and it's it's like the actual film
making process like the the positioning
of the shots and the framing and the
pacing of those
movies uh and then I Goblet of Fire is
kind of like the that's usually the one
that people hate a lot
I don't hate it as much as most people
Goblin of fire probably has my I think
the most well done scene maybe of the
whole movie series is Voldemort's
return like they botched a lot in that
movie it's so wrong and off and they had
to cut a lot cuz that book was huge but
the way that they like that whole scene
with Voldemort's Resurrection like you
had to nail one scene for that movie to
be
halfway redeemable and they nailed that
that scene is so good
man so I don't know about
movie but book is
easy book is very easy for me Silver
Legion welcome in Ryan Lawson how's it
going hey appreciate it Ryan glad you've
been enjoying the
streams baggie you got this on the
we gave up after like three missions oh
no call me Gigi welcome in new to the
channel you've played this game only on
easy couldn't handle it the other day
you still no cuz the trophy guide I
recommended speaking of trophies guys it
it recommends that
you it actually recommends that you
start on
hard I'm like why shouldn't I play on
easy first and like get the hang of it
I'll put it up to chat what do you guys
you guys are you guys will want to see
hard I know Alicia welcome in also uh Ro
rolloff watching the stream from the
Netherlands let's go yo I like your
little icon too that looks very similar
to our R here that we
updated mac and cheese good morning good
morning welcome
in Lord
raafa welcome
in yeah I've heard it I've heard it's
pretty rough I have heard it's a pretty
rough
game chamber Secrets best movie for you
silver
Legion yeah mag and chees there's
something missing from
those remaining ones I think so Bob Dole
oh my goodness Bob thank you for
stopping by I'm old enough to know who
Bob Dole is some of the younger ones are
probably like
who Bob I'm pretty sure he passed away a
while back now I need to look this
up
yeah let's see 2021 so it wasn't that
long
ago former uh us
politician but I have not played it
before Bob I have never played
it never played
it
Max silver David Yates ruin the fridge a
lot yeah a lot of people don't like
aren't big fans of David Yates like once
they started
rotating I feel like they should have
just stuck with that but they they let
him just stay on and see it all the way
through because I think the story always
was that any director they would they
actually offered them if they wanted to
stay on I don't know if that's true or
not but I mean it sounds like it would
be true because they let Columbus did
too honestly I would have loved to see
what Columbus would have done with all
of them but that's that's like a huge
commitment you know huge
commitment yeah exactly wook the scene
that will forever
live forever uh be embedded into our
minds as like what have you done with
Dumbledore cuz we were already just you
know Goble of fire were just starting to
get used to gambing as Dumbledore just
very different from the Richard Harris
portrayal I feel like if you could take
Richard Harris's portrayal and take
Michael gamon's portrayal and like find
this happy medium that would be the
perfect
Dumbledore because I love I love like
the look of the Richard Harris
Dumbledore but imagining him like doing
some of those later scenes like it's
just that's tough you know he was so
kind of I guess he was so kind of uh
frail he was older at the time when he
did
those but it but for the the Harry
Potter reboot man dude I was watching
expecto Go's stream one day when they
were doing James was like doing all the
uh getting casting from the
chat Richard Harris's
son what is his name jonath is it
Jonathan
Harris no who is Richard Harris's son
Jared Harris dude that guy could be the
new Dore
man like you put a full beard on
him I that he's my pick dude he is my
pick for the Harry Potter reboot when
they do the
show oh no not Richard har Jared har
yeah Jared Harris okay I want to see how
old he is how much would they have to AG
him Jared Harris is currently 62 dude
that's like with a little
makeup oh yeah he's that's the one
that's who we
need don't Christian gamer said don't
start on hard do medium at most Arvin
says it's a nightmare on
hard Derek see Derek I think that's the
strategy of the trophy guy I was reading
they were like if you can beat that then
it's all it's all good
play easy the game is terrible enough
call me Gigi says easy as well kisi says
medium okay the thing is do I need to
uh like you don't have to do them in any
specific order right cuz I know some
games you only unlock the hardest
difficulty yeah I don't think I don't
think there's anything to do with
that hey M store welcome in dude welcome
in
slamming oh yeah in in prisoner
basan yeah caric exactly that's what I
was
thinking Noob oh my goodness ladies and
gentlemen there's a name we haven't seen
in some time new welcome man dude how's
it been
going oh is there a direct today
Anthony I thought they just did a
PlayStation direct is there another
one I usually I used to watch those
things every time but now I'm just like
eh I'll just get the news
later but I totally understand like
people wanting to watch them
in and bask in the uh all the new stuff
all the new
announcements hey Devin welcome
dude right that's yeah exactly M stor
you'll have to play hard no matter what
if I want to go for the
Platinum nice good to hear Noob good to
hear man good to hear everything's going
well game with Joseph how's it going oh
a direct for Final Fantasy 7 that's
right I do remember seeing seeing the uh
update about that
and we got potterhead in the chat too
potterhead what's up dude welcome in all
right so for those of you just joining
if you I mean you probably already know
thanks to the
thumbnail but we're about to dive into
this bad boy for the first time ever
I've never played
it see Wario saying I feel like Wario is
trying to use reverse psychology now on
me Warrior's like don't bother man don't
bother don't don't even worry about
trophy hunting for this
game but I mean we our channel is based
on Wizarding World you guys can we
really even call ourselves a true Harry
Potter gamer if we don't get the
platinums in every available Harry
Potter game oh my
goodness this is like a dad joke on the
back
here look at it right in the
middle the Spells
War
who thought of that
one oh
man you know the marketing guys when
they came up with that this spells War
yes that's what's going on the back of
the box
that that's
it that's it This spells War
man this spells War I think it's time I
think it's time you guys let me fire up
the old PlayStation 3
here still running strong I think I
still have uh Half Blood Prince in there
hopefully there's not any updates or
anything oh goodbye sweet
prince the game that we enjoyed so much
platinum trophy
complete and Half Blood
Prince like how do they how did they go
from that to this I don't
understand I don't even now you get it
yeah yeah wait for it wait for
it this spells War ladies and
gentlemen this spells
War all right let's cut the Hogwarts
Legacy
music and let's see if we have to do any
kind of
update all right it's probably going to
be check for
update maybe they updated it man maybe
the game's like fantastic
now maybe it just needed a a a firmware
update that's all they had to
do
I think for the laughs oh man I'm trying
to decide on difficulty you
guys I'm trying to
decide so we got easy medium or hard a
connection wait
what all right hold on let me go back to
full cam for a
[Music]
bit oh dude that's actually
I love that music
though why do you not have an internet
connection we're streaming right
now yeah man what do you got like
easy like if I'm definitely
going for the
Platinum do I want my first
experience to
be oh there is internet connection what
are you talking
about do I want it to
be cuz the I think the pro thought
process is you get the hardest one out
of the way you get it out of the way and
then it's all smooth sailing from
there Wario does not want to see me
subject myself to
this I know right the P that old the old
school PS3 home screen
I actually missed the PS3 I think that
was they went away from that uh what do
they call it the cross media
bar I love the cross media bar I thought
it was a really good design and then
they just started doing something I feel
like they've gotten worse with those
like I feel like the PS5 one they're
designing it more to look like a
storefront which I guess is very
intentional but this one I just I don't
know I really liked the look of this one
all right I I don't know why it's still
saying that I'm not connected let me do
an internet connection test maybe they
just don't like the game it's just not
you can't even update it
anymore as Ron would say it's not worth
it it's not worth it Mrs rur oh my
goodness you guys she threw down the
gauntlet
there she threw down the
gauntlet I think we do I think we do
hard if Mrs Rak andur said it
like I think we got to listen to the
wife guys I think we got to
listen and this is a good point it's
definitely going to make for a funnier
stream also if I do decide we're going
for the Platinum then I can just do easy
and medium off stream and I don't have
to subject you guys to that a second and
a third
time
oh yeah it's failing the connection the
the connection speed I don't know we're
just going to play we're just going to
play no update man this is like the
original original version all right let
me also note the time
here all right people of the internet oh
no wait hold on let me write this
[Music]
down
people of the internets hello and
welcome to Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows part one ladies and gentlemen if
you didn't tune in for the just chatting
section if we're going to go for the
platinum trophy in this game we have to
beat it not
once not
twice but three full
playthroughs one on easy one on medium
one on hard
what you are about to watch what you are
about to see and witness here is our
first time ever playing Harry Potter and
the Deathly Hallows part one heard part
two is a little bit better we'll
see and we're going to do it on hard
mode ladies and gentlemen we're going to
do it on hard mode oh there we go an
update has been found to sign in you
must update the to the latest version
the system will quit oh my goodness you
got to be kidding me you told me you
couldn't do the update
you told me you told me you couldn't do
it oh
geez let's see if it'll go through
now oh yeah there it goes now I got to
do the intro again man we nailed the
intro we nailed
it I'm just going to leave it in replay
Squad if you want to skip ahead you can
skip ahead but I do that for the re
those who watch on replay because if I
go back and watch I can see like
everybody skips the gist chatting and
they just want to get straight to the
gam playay so replay Squad if you go
ahead in time about like three minutes
probably you'll be where you
need dude I have to keep switching the
monitor over voltage welcome in dude you
love the uh the thumbnail nice yeah I
have I have fun doing those little uh
throwing my face on the Harry Potter box
Arts just for a little bit of a
different look to it fail the up yeah
imagine if the update doesn't even go
through it just fails and I can never
load the
game the universe trying to save
me the the game designers of the game
channeling their energy to me being like
no don't play it don't play it you
really do Wonder like how a game like
this even gets made though right because
you
know me after just playing Half Blood
Prince like they did so many good things
with half blood prints so it's like do
you throw everything out the window or
was it just a matter of time crunch now
to be fair we C we can give the game
devs this at least is that the vast
majority of it has to take place outside
of
Hogwarts so they I mean they probably
knew going in that it it couldn't be the
same type of game you
know it couldn't be now if imagine like
if a Deathly Hallows in more of a
Hogwarts Legacy style like that combat
and that level of
Freedom now that that could have been
pretty good but everything I've heard
about this one is like they took the
whole
uh shooter Gears of War shooter era and
just brought it over to
Potter brought it over to Harry Potter
ruy welcome in dude welcome all right
the update has
proceeded I think we should just I think
we just do the intro again and you guys
who were here you just get to see double
the
intro yeah let's do that let's let's do
that but then
people oh great the required game data
is going to be
installed we're not off to to the best
of starts here I didn't even know this
oh my gosh are you kidding
me no shot
dude oh my gosh please start moving okay
hold on 2% let's see how long it takes
to get to
three okay right here's what we're gonna
do here's what we're gonna do we're
going to go back here going to pull up
some uh go back to our Hogwarts Legacy
music we're just GNA catch up with you
guys there we go how's your day going
man what are you guys getting into today
I'm just going to kick back I'm going to
relax I didn't even remember this was a
thing on
PS3 having to
install I guess I guess it did start
with the PS3 era
meore aren't the trophies stacked what
do you
mean what do you mean aren't the
trophies stacked it requires three
playthroughs no no no no oh I I know
what you mean now like some games you
beat it on hard you automatically get it
triggers for medium and easy nah that'd
be too that'd be too generous of them
you know that'd be too kind Harry Potter
and the Deathly
Hallows part one trophy guide
let's see
here I'm going look at a couple
different ones because okay so I'm
looking at playstationtrophies.org yeah
road map their step one is complete the
game on
hard oh chat I think you guys are just
setting me up listen to what they say to
begin jump right into the game and
select hard difficulty hard isn't
particularly taxing but there may be a
few tough spots
okay just remember to stay in cover and
take your time as there is no rush to
get through the game all story trophies
as well as a few extras will be unlocked
in this playthrough I managed to obtain
the defeated what
1,000 defeated 1,000 enemies trophy just
about 10 minutes before completing the
game so it should be obtained in this
playthrough as long as you kill every
enemy you come across the trophy reach
level 20 should be unlocked as well
completing the game on hard will net you
the Order of the Phoenix recruit
trophy then they say complete it on
medium then they say complete it on easy
and also get the extra Story related
trophies all right let me look at a
different a different uh guide here TR
trophies.com oh they don't have like a
little road
map okay here we go this is uh
xboxachievements.com
it will take you at least three
playthroughs the difficulty achievements
don't stack hard difficulty won't be
that much of a
challenge well chat what do we have here
not one but two websites saying hard
difficulty won't be that much of a
challenge and the other two playthroughs
shouldn't take you that long to complete
there are six achievements related to
collectibles in the game a video collect
guide can be found here you will unlock
13 achievements by simply playing
through the story other achievements are
tied to kills leveling up and using
potions and
spells
okay connect
achievements thank goodness we got the
PS3
version oh my gosh they had connect
achievements Warrior you you haven't
played through all of the game
before
oh that's a good point too Christian
gamer they were split into two separate
movies so they had to split into two
separate
games yeah they didn't have as much time
and then they also had a very limited
thing they could focus on
right yes Olo welcome in thank you for
stopping by Jay Rossi in the house
too Jay Rossy dude it's been a while
wait and I see DVD H in the chat too
welcome in good to see you good to see
you as
always oh Wario with another good point
the Half Blood Prince movie was delayed
by one year so they had an extra year to
work on it dude look what happens when
you give them some
time look what
happens all right let's check let's
check on our update guys oh
61% we're rolling man we're rolling one
eternity later now we def we have to do
the intro again
now we have to redo the intro for the
just chatting shifting into our gameplay
segment I know how many it's probably
like two something small
potterhead the PC version of this game
and part two scans what language your
windows and set to and doesn't let you
switch
what I know ruie we're our patience is
already going to be
tested a and voltage thank you for
subscribing welcome in guys on the last
stream we went over 60,000 subscribers
thank you guys so much man we got a goal
of hitting 100K by the end of the year
so if you're watching right now and
you're having a good time you think you
might want to check out the channel a
bit more make sure you sub subscribe
before you go it's free doesn't cost
anything and if you love The Wizarding
World man then this is definitely a
channel you want to keep an eye on all
the latest news theories discussion on
not just Hogwarts
Legacy but theme parks new TV shows all
the above all the above so appreciate
you guys for hanging out on the stream
today and also
subscribing
I know Anna yeah we're just off to a
fantastic start the PS3 knows how bad
this is they're trying to stop me
military man you played it once on uh
normal oh you said you play on regular
normal
gotcha the friends section part in the
last fourth four and F I was wondering
about that too
Bill because isn't it an online trophy
[Music]
okay wait Deathly Hallows part one
Trophy
Guide if we can't get the if we if it's
impossible to get
the that trophy that we need
then I'm probably not going to play on
hard yeah online
challenges there are four online
trophies for this first showing
comprehensive showing survivalist and
friendly
Rivals hard Challenge number five to get
the survivalist
trophy oh man we got to figure out if
you can still even get it or
not H somebody said bad game but easy
Platinum it's an obligation for us
Trophy Hunters
speaking to my soul right there my
friend this game is a pain somebody else
says there is no chapter select or scene
select first time I played through it I
beat it on hard but ran from every enemy
in sight oh no so I didn't get to level
20 or kill 1,000 enemies you should get
that in your next playthrough anyway I
would
think other guy says I ran past them
only killing a few along the way then at
the end you have to kill all the enemies
there then you'll get
it oh I see I got annoyed and wanted to
see what would happen if I just ran and
it worked oh that's good to
know other people are like you have to
beat this game three
[Music]
times oh wait also the online compare
trophy all you have to do is post the
score on online via another account that
is within the top 1,000 on the
leaderboard oh no no no I don't like the
sound of this we got to worry about
online
leaderboards dude it may actually not
even be possible to get the the Platinum
anymore oh
no okay a post from August of 2015
says replaying on this replaying this on
a new account on the challenges it's
pretty difficult now to get onto the top
1,000
leaderboard I have to get onto the
Top If you have difficulty to be in the
top 1,000 leader boards you can simply
complete one of the five Elite
challenges knowing that not a lot of
people have done
them
okay
okay another post says if you're
thinking about buying this game
don't it's
[Music]
atrocious okay somebody from April 2019
said underrated advice much easier to do
this way in 5 minutes I had a top 100
time on the elite one challenge I'm
guessing there aren't even a thousand
entries on the leaderboard for this
one the sequence is I don't even know
what they're talking about the sequence
I guess you have to put in some kind of
code oh brother we're going to have some
fun
streams we are going to have some fun
streams oh here we
go all
right I think we're finally
ready different breed of gamer I can do
it
man yeah it's like does the online
leader board even
exist all right so we're going to redo
our intro now at 43 minutes into the
stream it's all right gave us some time
to catch up chat gave us some time okay
4315 we'll
say people of the internet hello and
welcome to Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows part one ladies and gentlemen
the rumors are true we're about to play
this Gem of a game I've heard it's
fantastic if you guys are watching this
on the replay Squad thank you so much
for stopping by we had a little bit of
trouble getting everything up and
running I'm not sure if that's a sign of
things to come but here we are just know
you can always join us and watch these
live as well if you're curious about the
just chatting section there are time
stamps down below you can jump back and
see that but we are getting ready to
jump in I've never played this game
before never played it I don't even
think I've really watched it being
played other than when I've made some
videos based on the previous games and
so before we started playing here we
were looking into the trophy guide
because you guys know I love my Platinum
trophies and this is one of the first
few Potter games to actually have a
platinum
trophy here's the
problem you have to beat it not
once not twice but three times you have
to beat the game three full times on
hard on medium and on
easy all the trophy guys we have Rec we
have looked at recommend Doing Hard
first my chat is telling me it's about
50/50 some people are saying do not put
yourself through this other people are
here for the lulls they're here for the
laughs and they want me to go all in on
hard mode so ladies and gentlemen you
know what we got to do you know what we
got to
do we go big or we go home hard mode
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
part one retro rack and
tour let's do this
thing all right well so far so good I
like the menu very simplistic setting
the mood now see we knew going into
Deathly Hallows they were going to have
to do something different so much of the
game takes place outside of Hogwart
School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry all right let's take a look at
the options here before we jump
in I wonder what they say about uh
unlock
menu ooh okay this is interesting let's
turn subtitles
on I'm going to
turn oh man you guys know we've been
getting just absolutely destroyed with
the almost said the word the YouTube
inquisitorial squad on the music issues
so here's what we're going to do for
this first stream of the game I'm gonna
have it about
halfway have it about half a little bit
past the halfway point and if it's a
problem like if it does get flagged then
next time we can turn it
off yeah I want I want to make sure you
guys can at least hear it a little bit
so we'll do right there all right we got
subtitles on controller
setup aim
assist Harry Potter game that needs aim
assist o
buddy oh yeah hold on let me check
brightness too for some reason I don't
know if it's this monitor but it's
always a little bit
darker than I would
like uh I think we're it doesn't it
doesn't even give you really anything to
just some clouds to look at here so I'll
just trust that that we're good
hopefully that's that's good all right
new
game oh yeah we're doing it you thought
I was kidding no
sir no sir
mer laap Essence hey it's kind of like
uh the souls games they're giving us a
little during the loading screen well
this is already different from Half
Blood prints which are dark times there
is no denying our world has faced no
greater threat than it does
today there have been
disappearances murders but I say this
your Ministry remains strong we will
keep the people safe ooh it's a little
quiet turn it up a bit for you
guys I believe you know our guest Miss
charity let me know if it's too loud
Muggles and all their way or if you
can't can't hear
it bro this scene was so creepy reading
it what news
the order has learned that we have
infiltrated the
ministry they are moving him
tonight what is there have been too vort
voice where Harry Potter is
concerned tonight I will kill Harry
Potter in
person turn up a bit more okay everybody
ready once we get to the burrow you'll
be safe and if anyone attacks us on the
way all disguised to shoot Death Eaters
will never know who the real one
is hold
tight gaming for justice welcome
dude oh here we go
man call of Potter look around using R
okay
hello
Hagrid oh does it just does it want me
to like
just oh my goodness R2 to
cast now I could see this doing really
well on the Wii spells are cast
spells cast are more accurate if aimed
first press and hold L2 oh okay so you
can like you got a little ads here aim
down
sights oh wait does that lock
on I think it actually locks
on
stup
oh
you man hearing their uh their Grunts
and stuff you're
like and this I mean this could have
been such an epic video game scene
right you keep casting I put a few
tricks obviously all right Hagrid Hag
look out see the
tricks here we go again
this jumping toad
stool oh my goodness what is this we got
like I feel like I'm playing uh
literally it's like a Call of Duty car
chase sequence hold they up
there this just do not feel like a Harry
Potter game man this is so funny
okay wait do I hear a guy behind
me I hear them but oh there he
is
stupy
stupy bro trying to aim this while the
might actually turn the sensitivity down
a
bit and I know my controller I got the
message my controller is dying too
but I've got my spare here ready to go
as soon as this one
dies
come on
you come on
Harry ha ha it my index finger is
already getting tired it's not a good
sign wonder if I can just hold
down oh man of course that'd be too easy
you can't just hold down
R2
do I even have a health bar or anything
maybe not for this scene cuz it's on
Rails
stup these beg won't catch
us that voice these beggar won't catch
us is Hagrid from the south
now
[Music]
is Hagrid from the United
States I'm not even making fun man
that's where I'm from
dude these Beggars won't catch us super
do you call them
Beggars hurry what oh man where have
they gone I don't know what's happened
where they've gone are you all right
hurry it's him who hurry it's baltimor
mine oh my
goodness there he
is
oh oh he's got like the full health bar
man the the the invisible health bar
though we can't see
it Hagrid why are you are you getting
hit somewhere I think he
is oh that's great game design you can't
even hit that guy over
there all right I feel like I need to
get all the other guys away first like
this dude over here keeps hitting hag
there we go but I can't aim at
them like that guy right there come on
Hagrid let me shoot through your
arm that's it
hurry there's more of them behind us you
just said that's it bro
no oh they they cut out the part of who
dies right there I
see all right well first first
scene all right we're here we're rolling
not too crazy not too bad
yet quickly it's Harry Dad Dad
here imagine if that was actually the
graphics run blurry like that quickly
he's coming round Harry Harry are you
all
right what where am I where's Hagrid
what about Voldemort it's all right
Harry Hagrid's fine and the orders put
protective charms on the burrow we're
safe for now I shouldn't be here I'm
putting everyone in danger careful you
can't rush after what you've been
through besides we can't go anywhere
till after the
wedding what wedding been and Flur we
would have told you but been sort of
unconscious you'd better get ready me
you can't expect him to go to the
wedding like
this just take your time Harry make sure
you're all right Ron's right if I can't
go to a wedding how am I supposed to
find the other H cres Dumbledore's gone
we have to finish started we have to
destroy
Voldemort I've been wondering Voldemort
you know who hid his soul in h cres
right and two have been destroyed right
do you think he knows that part of him
is dead I don't care yeah let's just
find the other four and Destroy what
remains can we talk about this later
please we shouldn't spoil Bill and
Flair's big
day why do you have your wand draw Harry
it's a wedding oh my goodness okay there
we
go he's like about to go into this
wedding man there we go a bumpy Landing
trophy number
one oh what a wonderful tent I can't
wait for the down in hello hello nice to
see
you good evening good evening blim me
seems Looney runs in the jeans who is
that Luna's father xenophilus we should
say
hello he supported Harry all through the
summer when the prophets were ignoring
the truth besides it might be the last
chance we get to speak to
it's strange thinking everyone be back
at Hogwarts without us press Circle at
any time to cast four points and learn
where to go next four points will show
you the most direct route to your
destination but not
always I don't know what it said that
last word wonderful tent I can't wait do
I have to cast I I don't want to cast
yet I want to talk to all these folks
here
forever here he put the wand down dude
he's like are you vult are you him oh
just fine are you working with him no
sign of them getting married yet let
alone grandkids but then with everything
that's going on at the
moment you believe the rumors how long
until it just Auto casts it for
me I just want to look around man just
want to look
around how far can we walk up here
before
it ah I don't want to mess anything up
talk oh wait we can R I hope Luna's dad
doesn't start trying to tell us about
crumple horn snorkacks or narles not
always the safest okay thank you
potterhead yeah I missed that
part hello Mr love good ah I trust you
know Mr Potter that we at the quibbler
fully support a Dumbledore during his
lifetime
and in his death support you just as
fully uh thanks is Luna with you she
lingered in that Charming little garden
such a glorious infestation of gnomes or
to give them their correct name the
jumbly
gardeni you might want to congratulate
Mr Weasley on them he was looking for
you just now thanks yeah I I will see
you later bill have a good one uh
informed you Mr Weasley is looking for
you
okay they definitely don't want you to
explore much they're like cast the spell
please all right let's cast
it oh wait Mr Weasley what dude that's
the way that's the way we were going
anyway so they don't want me to actually
go inside yet it looks like everybody's
still waiting out
here can I run can we can we move faster
oh we can switch switch the shoulder
there Mr Weasley must be up
there where do we even start to look for
thees we don't even know what hey R
what's up dude yes there are two games
destroyed the ring and found the locket
yeah but that was a fake wasn't it but
it looked like the real one somewhere
there's the real locket the real H
cracks and from what I've heard they're
both not good but the second one is is
improved over the first one to Bon with
her really Bo
Bon so far the voice
acting
fantastic just excellent Hagrid's my
favorite so
far let's see what he wants oh yeah I
didn't want to turn let me
uh I'm going to lower the sensitivity
Let's Do by
two yeah
there he
is Mr
Weasley did you want to speak to us ah
yes yes I did you see it turns out that
Dumbledore left you things in his will
huh all of us oh that's right yes to you
Ron he left his deluminator not how it
happened in the book but to
herion his copy of the tales of beetle
The Bard and to you Harry he left the
snitch you caught in your first quiddit
match he also left you the Sword of
godric
Gryffindor but the ministry is insisting
the sword wasn't dumbledor to give away
not that it matters because no one can
find the sword
anyway did he say what these were for
I'm afraid he didn't yeah this now this
is not how it happened to your rooms and
come down to the party we have a wedding
to celebrate don't
we my mom used to read me the tales of
beetle The Bard
how are children's story supposed to
help us find the H cruxes don't know
maybe dumor just wanted to cheer us up
do you think all these things are a
clue are there supposed to be fireworks
before
the the ministry has swen the minister
of magic is dead they are
coming oh we don't even get to see
inside
oh great here we go all right so how do
I
take uh when close to cover press square
to take shelter
okay oh my
goodness those are more
accurate get the cover
okay
[Music]
cover head shot let's
go these are dark times is no
denying yeah that wasn't that was a
different voice too that was not scrim
[Music]
Jour I I don't see any like health bar
or anything so oh man I'm kind of
blocking Harry's head aren't
I I'm going to move my webcam after
this
let's see
here it's still cutting it
off let's go right
side
are you having fun yet right Shina talk
wait who are we talking
to wait did we get them all where' they
go oh I guess we did get
them okay are miny where are the others
Harry we need to
leave all right let's leave how do we
leave we have to stop oh wait I can do
the spell I can do the spell yeah yeah
yeah show me which way to
go ooh hold L1 to cast a protective
spell
stup yeah we're going to have to figure
out how that works it it's definitely
not just it's definitely not just a tap
you have to hold
it uh-oh okay so there's our health
meter right there the screen starts to
turn starts to turn black and white that
must be in the
test fall an enemy enemies occasionally
drop useful items wait
what oh great now I'm blocking Harry
over here it
just it just depends on which side he's
on you don't think you know who's coming
do
you O A strengthening solution of course
a blood replenishing potion why
not welcome back
Alicia all right I think we
go
wait which way do we
go which oh this way
okay oh my goodness right in front of
me I feel like I need a Dodge move can I
like can we not dive to the left and
right that's the one thing they're
missing
here dude Prego just feels
useless first of all it takes forever to
cast hry wait how are
you hey I don't know what we did with
cego but a strong Shield let's
go out of was there another enemy back
here I want to get them all I want to
try to make sure we get that
trophy REM he was shooting at somebody I
thought
but hurry we need to go okay wait hold
holding X he goes a little bit faster
what do you guys think I'm doing we need
to Ron and Hermione sheesh Harry we need
to
leave apparatus out of here
then
a potion that can be used to heal major
injuries all right hey another the dude
trophies are flying fast I love it
Joseph gamer welcome in dude it's going
well so
far making our way on hard mode we need
to change through what I've heard is the
worst Harry Potter game ever
made at least one of the top two with uh
Goin of fire up there as well already
made it through go people here could be
death e how would the death eers know we
were here they've known where we were
every other time the mugle news is full
of natural disasters but we know what
that really means though death
ears I brought your visibility cloak
Harry I thought it would be useful oh
here we
go here we go Christian gamer most of
the order was there they'll look after
everyone do you really think there could
be death eers here to be sure
you have been discovered
oh what it tells me to put the cloak on
everyone's all right after we most of
the order stepped out they'll look after
everyone do you really think there could
be Death Eaters here best to be sure I
don't know gaming for justice I feel
like it'd be a good time to do
it all right death eers could be
anywhere take Ron's advice and check out
the newspaper
seller
[Music]
why' they make it so
blurry the newspaper where is he
at stand still to decrease chance of
being
discovered or just walk over
here bumping into someone will lead to
Discovery
okay
oh yeah this
is these are going to be bad man these
are going to be
frustrating wait where where's the
newspaper oh and the little Deathly
Hallow symbol is like your
detection oh I'm about to be
detected that's
garbage why is it full
oh that dude he's looking right at me
just get in your car
leave
okay oh my goodness there's people right
there
too Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
ladies and gentlemen part
one this is what we all I mean when when
you when you
imagine a game taking you you
through the sequence of events in Harry
Potter and the Deathly
Hallows I don't know what's more
riveting than walking through the
streets with the invisibility cloak man
I don't know dude I don't
know every time you walk it goes
down oh it runs
out okay let's just like take it off for
a
second dude they didn't have to do the
just total blurred
vision I mean that alone would have been
a an incredible Improvement not having
that okay we got to find this oh wa I
keep forgetting let's just do the
spell oh but then oh we can't still see
it let's
go so wait what is the what is the green
even measuring I thought it was like my
how it's C me being detected
but I was saying I think the other day
that you needed to change it I'm more
concerned about what's happening with
all strange storms don't bump into them
oh yeah this dude here's the newspaper
only a p now you paper only a p oh
man that that could be rough definely h
symbol is when you walk and it goes down
when it's empty you can't use the cloak
anymore oh interesting quietly sneak
back to Ron and inform him that the
newspaper seller is a muggle not a Death
Eater all right I'm on it is that what
you really think I'm not so Keen okay
and this is good news you can cast
this while you're under the cloak we
have to get
everything
wait oh back here okay I see
them
Maga welcome dude well I am so sorry uh
I mean we're still pretty early we had a
I didn't know we were coming did I we
had a little update that we had to do
before we were able to dive in it's
about planning but so far I would say
it's about what I
expected the newspaper salesman is a
mugle yeah well we can't be too careful
what about that woman over there did you
check her
out sneak over to the woman with the
sign we were just right by her why
couldn't we have done this when we were
already over
there because that would have made too
much sense oh yeah we were right beside
her we were right beside that
lady great don't get hit Harry come on
[Music]
open she's not a death wait how is Harry
even how is he telling if
they're I guess he knows all their
identities oh you've been discovered try
again
no Mission failed wait do we have to
wait wait wait wait wait do we have to
do it all again okay good just the woman
all right
I was about to say man imagine if we had
to do the first person again too the
newspaper yeah how does he tell I mean I
guess if he knows the identity of all
the Death Eaters I can't imagine that he
does the way the game is playing it off
it's like he walks up he's like hm no
you look nice I don't think you're a
Death
Eater that's how he's checking
oh I knew we could get out here some way
there we
[Music]
go she's not a Death Eater Not a Death
Eater
but okay can I get through
here okay I have to take it off don't
I yeah can I put it back on oh you can
put it back on right away all right nice
nice
nice I think Harry's still got the trace
on him maybe that's how the Death Eaters
keep finding Here I Am the trace breaks
when he turns 17 and Harry's not been
here he can read magical yeah
something's giving away where we
are the woman with the sign is a mugle
too looks like we've lost those Death
Eaters
then head to the C CFE so you can hide
out for a
while yeah who was it Jenny that said
this is just
filler it is so I mean they are just
trying to find what can we have them
do for this portion of the
game
where is
it this
it where is the
cafe does yeah maybe that's it J
Rossy doesn't smell like a Death Eater
oh this looks like the diner here we
go oh now now we're now we're cool with
being
seen where' We Go From Here the Leaky
cauldron too dangerous if vot's taken
over the ministry none of the old places
are
safe let's sit over there we can work
out what to do
next what do you think
Harry
sry now we got oh now those guys they
totally look like Death Eaters
right oh wait I've still got the cloak
on it's like boss battle or something
right
here I don't understand the point of
foro I just don't understand it press
and hold R1 for spell wheel whoa are we
learning a new
spell I mean I guess if you can see the
spell
coming take that
dude it is unreal that this game got
made I'm just going to say are there
anymore find us did this game get weate
away from here yeah where can we
go oh man it is order the Phoenix is
just fetch quests this is just I mean
spamming R2 over and over and over okay
I needed that I needed needed that
trophy pop to
uh oh man now I need a little bit lower
for the we can see the trophy popping up
criminal Place Undead Joe welcome come
here
again you think it's
safe
wait oh yeah forgot about this
part what
what was
that it must be one of the jinxes the
order used to protect the house I didn't
think death eties could get into grimel
place no but then they weren't supposed
to know we were moving Harry
either wait why are we in
first what why are we in first person
find the
kitchen
are we playing a horror game now what is
going
on what is going on hey Oscar thank you
for subscribing appreciate it welcome in
I didn't see what it said what did it
say guys blast these oh goodness I'm mad
at me
now
stupy
stupy is this what I
need okay now how do I throw
it spells are now more
powerful okay we got more over here hey
the benefit of
experience hold on let me move the cam
just a little bit
lower got to make sure we see those
trophies popping in
there we got to have some some sort of
reward for playing through
this like is the potion doing anything
to
them okay it kind of stuns them
then we can finish them
off what is happening
man they just keep
attacking there we
go there's a leveling up
system just kind of like a hidden one I
guess after you fire your spell so many
times all right search grimal Place wait
what what is that even
mean look in every
room look out for Wizard newspapers the
daily prophet and the quibbler while
exploring they have news of current
events do you think someone's here
the should keep people out but let's
check to be sure we don't want any nasty
surprises why are we why are we first
person yes I don't
understand why did they want to make
this part first
person okay that room apparently is good
we don't need to check that
one oh
great new spell unlocked impedimenta
press R2 to cast the spell hold R2 for
longer R1 to select hey and we reach
level
three
oh we're about to die yeah we did we
died they got
[Music]
us oh great and I don't I don't keep the
new spell that we unlocked we have to go
back up there to get it
again proba to make it harder right
someone's here protective spells The
Order cast should keep people out I
can't think of any other
we don't want
super give me the new
spell okay there it
is like do I have to push x on it
or come on oh my
goodness this is okay our first we are
playing on the hard difficulty this is
our first time dying back to back like
that I'm assuming there's a newspaper
here somewhere too why else would they
tell me that do you think someone's here
the protective spells The Order cast
should keep people out is there a
newspaper anywhere on the wall maybe
want any nasty
surprises my gosh it's so dark
too yeah exactly wook it's like come on
guys you could help me out up
here all right I'm going to stand back a
little bit here stup dude they are on
you so quick okay let's try to get to
the other side of the
room all
right no no we're going to die again
we're going to die
no oh my goodness all
right about to get
annoyed do I have to use the impedimenta
on
them I wonder if it's better I mean I'm
I'm assuming it maybe is
because that's the time they're giving
it to us the protective spells The Order
cast should keep people out I wonder if
I can back up like like go back through
this door oh we might be able to nice oh
great now it shuts of
course just back
up is that spell even doing any what
what the spell is not even doing
[Music]
anything why is it not doing
anything oh are there two uh are there
two of those things in here
Dylan when I get to the top of these
stairs it's like hey there's uh
two yeah wizard
newspapers do you think someone's here
the protective hit them with impediment
then hit them with superi yeah that's
what I let's check to be sure we don't
want all right so now that we know we
can't back out of the door we just got
to rush in
Che okay we we unlocked it quickly that
time come
on it's just bouncing off of them look
at
that why is it just bouncing off of
them
what I don't understand why is it
bouncing off of
them
okay I'm I need to read very carefully
this time do you think someone's here
the protective spells The Order cast
should keep people out but let's check
to be sure
super hold R2 for longer
burst I'm
holding oh there we
go all right we did we did take one out
that time though we did take one
out all right that's that's a good sign
that's a good
sign death by doxy dude multiple deaths
by doxy here this is
crazy and I wonder if my current spell
is doing anything to
them do you think someone's so I guess
the down how you can do that little
rapid fire these are stronger doxies
than what we encountered down
downstairs this is so dumb man this is
so
dumb
why is it like
this who warned me about this I think it
was Christian gamer wasn't it when
they're surrounded by clouds they're
immobilized so do you really think we
have to follow up like we have to switch
like it doesn't even give you the time
to do
it
it doesn't even give you time to fire
one and then fire the
other confing go is the best spell oh
but you you unlock it
later never finish the game on easy
we're trying this on hard right now
ladies and
gentlemen because for some reason some
part of me wants the platinum trophy in
this game
do you think someone's here the
protective oh this is our first this is
our first big uh stumbling block here
that's for sure don't want
any like Carrie can you not move any
faster about to have to look up a guide
for hard
mode how to beat
doxy hard mode Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows the protective spells
The Order cast should keep but let's
check to be sure melania's got nothing
on these doxies man see if I could just
back out like if I
could
stup
but then they lock the door on you man
they lock the
door keep somehow I I don't know why the
doxies have that ability okay there we
go that's good that's good that's
good no we got that
one oh Dylan with the Super Chat thank
you dude appreciate appreciate it $2
Super Chat dox the side in the kitchen
didn't I already I I used them all I
think no not player
two
uh turn off
controller why is it detecting this is
player
two here we go
can I actually get more in
here throw the potion wait do I I have
five of them now I've got presents my
good see I thought we used them all I
thought we used them all already oh my
goodness you guys okay so maybe it's
not all right all right all right hold
on hold on hold
on
oh you meant behind them well I think
we've got some anyway who said
that
Camilo thank you dude the protective
spells theorder see I didn't even think
we had anymore cuz it it looked like we
were just picking them up and using them
one at a
time yeah what do you guys think what do
you think about that doxy yeah
yeah here have another
one
oh my goodness you guys we did it we did
it hold on you tell me there's nothing
even in this room that we needed to
find
what there has to be a point of this
room
Stupify or is it literally just Harry
coming up here to be like all clear guys
don't worry that's what it was that's
what it was those were the initials in
the fake H Crux the one I found with
dumbledor Crux piece of ort s but how do
we find it creature
creature I wouldn't trust that house out
as far as I could throw Hagrid creature
used to live in the kitchen downstairs I
bet he's still
there find
creature discover where the hor CRS is
all
right once again I ask why are we in
first person right now so SS like
creature I hope he's doesn't make any
sense he's been alone so
long he betrayed serious child isn't
worthy to is creature
regulus owned a locket didn't
he where is it creature doesn't know but
did you see it creature does not talk to
Mud Bloods creature does not betray his
master regul black I'm your master now
creature what did regulus tell you to do
with the locket destroy it it was his
last order to creature but no matter how
creature tried he could not creature
betrayed his master creature could not
destroy the locket or what happened to
it what happened it's no use Harry he's
used to being shouted at you'll have to
think of something
else
dang give creature the
locket here
creature
I I want you to have
this we want to finish what Master
regular
started we want to destroy the real
locket Mangus Mangus Fletcher he took
the locket creater I want you to find
him please find
Mangus
off he
goes Harry said
calmly oh okay search for grandal play
all right we're still searching for
something what we need to look for now
hey I'm mining let's check the house
okay make sure it's safe more doxies
then I'm
assuming
all right so we can't check that room
wait I heard a
door oh this room
okay press X to collect potterwatch
password to listen to potterwatch
programs press start to pause the game
and select the Collectibles
menu whoa okay this is kind of cool
Potter watch Pals of Potter
p and now over to rapia for our popular
feature
pal our usual update on the friends of
Harry Potter we have heard within the
last few hours that rubius Hagrid
well-known gamekeeper at Hogwarts School
has narrowly escaped arrest within the
grounds of Hogwarts where he is rumored
to have hosted a support Harry Potter
party in his house however Hagrid was
not taken into custody and is We Believe
on the run I suppose having a 16t high
half brother helps when you're escaping
Death Eaters it would give you an edge
but while we here at po applaud Hagrid's
Spirit we would urge against following
Hagrid's lead support Harry Potter
parties are unwise in the present
climate especially with all we've heard
about the ministry running these
snatcher squads yes those haven't heard
the ministry his license soal snatchers
to hunt down and bring in anyone who is
deemed to be undesirable well that
wouldn't be us then would it I mean
we've both had loads of girlfriends it
must be those cute little cheeks and
whiskers rodent that's right tentacular
tentacular so to all those who find
themselves being unjustly labeled
undesirable we hear a salute you and to
all those people who really are
undesirable glorious UMD M your time
will
come dude all right that's a cool
feature man I like
that
well then we've got to collect quibbler
as well oh my goodness dude look how
many there's a lot of these and daily
profits all right well I'm not even
worried this first play through I'm just
going to find the Collectibles that we
come to I'm not going to really go out
of my way because if I actually go for
the Platinum that's the only time I'll
care about
the the
collectibles
and so I I would definitely want to do
that on my easy run when I'm not really
paying attention to the story or
anything okay
so do we need to check this room now oh
my
goodness
Boger when close to Dementors tap then
hold L1 to conjure a wait wait tap then
hold
I'm holding
on1
What tap then hold so like L1 let go and
then L1
again right do we have to find this
again no way it didn't save that
I'm not listening to it again but okay I
just want to make sure it was in
there Hey Joe Mac what is up dude
welcome
in just wanted to say hello before you
go back to work hey appreciate you
stopping by man guys for those who
aren't uh if you're a channel member
then you already saw my video Joe hooked
us up with all kinds of uh fun little
treats this I think this is my favorite
of everything this let me take the
little uh the little butterbeer it came
with these butterbeer candies in here I
can't wait to actually use
this but Joe appreciate it man too kind
of
you all right
so we got to figure out how to cast this
Patronis
L1 when close to Dementors tap then hold
so like L1
L1 there we
[Music]
go did we get
him I think we got him Dylan with the
five gifted
memberships Dylan my man thank you so
much dude appreciate it guys welcome to
house racking tour the clown Andrew
Robert Echo and Danny stormboard Danny
still here hanging out as well Danny if
you're lurking thank you for being here
guys make sure you thank Dylan if you
got one of those gifted
memberships and
enjoy your
emotes
enjoy your special role in Discord and
those uh videos that I was just
mentioning those members only videos we
just posted one yesterday which was way
longer than I anticipated it was like I
think it was like 30 minute video or
something so they're they're like uh we
do about once a month these little
behind the scenes members only
videos and being a member is just uh
it's it's a great way to support the
channel and everything we do here the
content we put out here and I just like
to give you guys the members a little
bit of something extra in return I know
the emotes are fun but I want to do I
want to go above and beyond give give
something a little bit more than that so
I've been doing these videos once a
month giving you guys little Channel
updates but then this one this last one
we had uh we had a lot to get through so
make sure you check out
those members only vids and also had a
members only Community post go up if you
guys didn't see
that may I think it went up this morning
it's either this morning tomorrow about
um getting feedback from you guys from
the channel members
on we need to update our loyalty badges
so that's another thing that you guys
get so like right there by Dylan's name
see how it's got the little retro
logo right there by potterheads name
it's got the retro logo jumping Toad's
name the retro logo those are uh channel
members wait a second Joe why is yours
not why does yours not show up are you
on a different name or something cuz I'm
like I know Joe is a member I saw Joe's
comment on the member only
video where am I supposed to back
upstairs I
guess but yeah we we need to update
those to go with the to fit better with
the Wizarding World theme and since
we're not using that logo on this
channel
anymore the little blue
logo
I still love that logo though I changed
my uh on our let's play Channel I
changed it to that logo
instead dude what
is okay back in here oh back downstairs
in the
kitchen get off me oh he's already back
Harry Potter that was quick what the
requested creature has return
the FL stupy
Stupify what is happening our
off are we supposed to blast him are we
supposed to just wait here hanging out
Stupify okay Hermione tell me any
suggestions try stunning him okay I did
I literally did
super maybe uh
impedimenta wait not invisibility cloak
hold
on
gete ourselves off
me you took a locket from here where is
it why oh got you Joe valuable you've
still got all good man have a good one
he's worried he should have got more
money for it this ministry egg may be
sell it practically stole it she did
Umbridge I think her name was Umbridge
yeah now I'll told you what you want you
can leave me out of
this Umbridge is Big at the ministry
again hardly leaves the place then we'll
have to find a way in that locket is the
only H Crux we know about we have to get
it talk to herione you do you realize
don't you that there's probably no more
dangerous place in the whole world for
us to be M's right mate they'll be on
the lookout for us can you think of
another way we'll have to do some
reconnaissance trips to work out the
safest way to get inside see you later
Harry oh my goodness how do they do this
in the game whilst Ron and hermy
investigate how to get into the ministry
Harry offers his assistance to fleeing
muggleborn in their struggle against
Voldemort's
forces
what
whoa whoa whoa what is this complete
these Encounters in any
order what is happening right
now what is
this hey DaNell welcome in I didn't see
you pop in
earlier okay so we can do these in any
order three like kind of missions the
abandoned substation these muggleborn
have been captured and Fa trial with the
ministry rescue them before the
snatchers can take them there the ruins
the forest has become home to muggleborn
trying to escape prosecution protect
these innocent witches and wizards from
the snatchers and the dark caves get to
the dark caves and fight back against
the Death Eaters and
snatchers I'm doing that one
first this is going to be
interesting
they were like the uh the level
selecting Goblin of
fire escape from the
drag a
dragon you said nothing about a Dragon's
Cave what is this elwin good morning
good morning welcome in we have no
invisibility cloak either spells are
ineffective against dragons of course
tread
carefully
can I not where's the invisibility cloak
man oh maybe we need to like hide behind
these dude this is like a dark souls
level go
Harry no no no no we're behind this
[Music]
rock
what did that say exploding
potion yeah yeah we know we
know got to use the rocks to hide yeah
[Music]
that's
get up come on pick up the
collectible it's gone just
disappeared what in the
world oh my
goodness hey it's all good GG have a
good
one what it doesn't even look like I'm
getting hit that's what's so confusing
right now
and for some reason Harry just doesn't
have his invisibility cloak
now you're like no no invisibility cloak
for
this okay no
fire let's just be real patient let's
just take one really
cautiously okay we got the
potion
all right now we got to get that green
one over
there I'm
stuck oh we're dead we're dead we're
dead we're
dead Harry come on please my man please
my man jump jump what are you doing
har literal dragon fire and you can't
jum jump over a rock I don't even know
where I'm supposed to
go I'm pretty sure we're not supposed to
be this close to
it
what mission failable come next
[Music]
time where I wish the game would tell me
oh wait I could do the
spell
all right we were doing so good that
time
[Music]
too I don't even know if I need all
these Collectibles but I want them
[Music]
all oh okay okay okay okay so let's grab
this hide behind this
one yeah then we can just just run out
right
here well you know he's coming
back you know he's coming
back run to the Rock
carry oh
wait that looks like something you could
explode right there
oh fire protection potion that's what
that said let's
go see they don't even give you time to
read what you're actually picking up
exploding
potion maybe that can we can throw that
at that little thing he
was oh my who are
you well hello
there what
rubian instant Darkness
powder oh my
goodness who who are all these people
and why are we just hanging out in a
dragon fighting
ring I feel like I'm in Hogwarts Legacy
all of the sudden only without the great
controls and
spellcasting the snatchers hey J Rossy
dudee always good to see you have a good
meal all right wait which
way point
me oh dude he's ready he's ready for
me oh fire protection
okay I See Fire Protection I'm just like
let's
go okay wait fire protection is running
out it is running
out okay right
there up this way don't stop don't stop
don't stop don't
stop oh daily
profit
possible to make platinum trophy without
PS5 um I'm not sure what you mean in
Hogwarts Legacy they have there's a
platinum trophy on
PS4 if if that's what you mean for the
PS4 version of Hogwarts
Legacy what no
sir fire protection spell go
I thought we were supposed to be helping
some Muggles who were trapped with
snatchers or
something no we're we're just like
making our way through a dragon
cave what in the
world more doxy side yeah you know we're
going to need that
oh now we're outside Mission completed
would you look at
that dark
caves Dragon Dodge hey I'll take the
trophy all right so now we just need the
ruins and the abandoned
station Let's do let's do the abandoned
station get some new
scenery you can't find the last
secondary mission
you only found it on YouTube and it's
only for
PS5 are you talking about the Haunted
Hogs me you shouldn't have to do that
one
for the trophy if I remember
right there are there were some uh some
kind of trophy bugs though I actually
ran into one but it eventually they they
did an update that fixed
it
wait where are these
people
oh we know you're
out see I just don't understand the
point of foro if it does
Harry fire the
spell you're free
ma' thank you wait weren't you at the
wedding thanks from all of us
oh muggle borns not actual
Muggles I mean I guess muggle borns are
mugle you guys know what I meant you
know what I what I was trying to
say
okay you have
Xbox oh I see
oh you've done everything without
counting the exclusive Mission o that's
interesting because I'm pretty sure that
one's not tied
to a
trophy an error has occurred you've been
signed out of
PSN yeah I don't know if we have any
Xbox players in here who might be able
to help with
that
oh you you can use the invisibility
cloak here
nice good to
know yeah to be honest with you guys
other than that little doxy section I
don't really feel like it's been all
that
hard and that was just because I forgot
about the
potion oh what is
this collect the Deathly Hallow
symbol
oh here we go
impediment oh oh oh we're about to die
here I shouldn't have said
anything oh no my cover's
blown
got there we go all
right no you you can use it right here
meor see
look now maybe it doesn't actually help
you but you you can use
it you don't remember the name of the
mission in English so it's like mind
your own business or something but I I'm
I'm pretty sure that that shouldn't be
required to get all the Xbox
achievements I don't even think it was
required to get all the trophies there
could be another one that you're missing
that you just haven't unlocked yet but
you said you've already done everything
else so it might just be oh I bet it it
could be the well one you guys remember
what was that one about the witch and
the
well that was one that a lot of people
missed like it doesn't pop up until you
go to that
area help me out chat
SOI welcome
in good morning or good afternoon
depending on where you're at maybe good
evening okay I didn't see another
muggleborn to save in that last
area wait who's shooting me oh down
there let me get cover
I was trying to use that Darkness powder
it didn't really do
anything Potter head hey thank you for
being here my friend have a good rest of
your
day just blast some from up
here oh you did the you did the well one
the well well well I think that's what
was called well well
well
Stupify
Stupify new spell let's go petrius to
Talis
oh it takes longer to fire that one in
the
world that's not petrificus is
it I think I have to be closer for that
one looks like Stupify is the only one
you can fire from behind
cover there we
go yeah see then as soon as I
actually can fire the other
one
pediment
yeah which which achievement
specifically is it that you're missing
like what's the name of the
achievement dude we need to take
cover come on don't take me out
yet there we
go
there we go got that
guy okay you're the one that's trapped
right is there somebody up here
now come on get up Harry get up you got
to move man you got to move
impediment there we
go like could they've not just put a
little Dodge button
in so I could at least roll left and
roll
right I keep pressing Circle trying
to cheers for that there you go that's
two the Good Samaritan one that tells
you to do all the secondary
missions I don't even remember that the
name of that one there's one spell that
shoots like a sniper
what okay Point
me let's
go this way
okay spy armis we don't have that one
yet oh wow look at
that
oh my goodness hiding out over here
huh more doxy
side that's good to know if we run into
any more of those doxies
hey defeat 100
enemies let's go let's
go yeah the soundtrack's pretty good one
of the redeeming qualities
here okay where we supposed to go
now this
way
impediment
look at that man taking them out left
and right let's
go silver trophy on PlayStation complete
all side quests ah
okay yeah I don't think I don't think it
had to be that one
though especially if you're on Xbox when
it's not even
available I would just look up like uh
I'm sure there's a like I always use
playstationtrophies.org or
powerpyx I'm sure there's an equivalent
for Xbox as well that you could find and
just see like look at all the missions
they say for that
trophy
oh yeah Ron and the beans oh Dementors
wait
what D mentors about to come
out that's
great oh no where's he
at oh they're over
there come on where's the Stag Harry
you have to be close to the Dementors if
I remember right for this spell to even
work oh are you leaving let's go get out
of here so wait it's the same
lady it's the same it was the same lady
again
it's the lady we met at the wedding it
was the first muggleborn We rescued
she's also the third muggleborn
oh my goodness okay nice Patricia thank
you yeah I I didn't think
so Ark mageddon what's this game called
This is the Glorious Harry Potter in the
Deathly Hallows part
one some say the worst Harry Potter game
ever made
we're pretty early in and uh yeah it's
bad it's not fun but it's all good cuz
I'm here hanging out with you guys you
guys make things a lot a lot easier to
uh chatting with you
all forgot how bad the game was
Jesse I just can't believe we saw that
we've seen that same lady three times
now
whoa that person trying to get all up
close and
personal
impediment thank you elwin and uh Dylan
I I
missed I missed whatever it was you guys
caught it before appreciate
it oh chz no worries no worries we just
uh we do keep things family friendly
here in the
Stream since we do have a number of uh
moms and dads and even some younger ones
who who
watch like can I shoot through the fence
here we can
nice all right how do we get through
there why is my point me spell not
working oh wait there's what where did
you come
from okay now Point
me oh there's a spot a hole in the fence
right
here NES Commander Pokemon meets fism
yeah I've heard uh expecto go pitch that
idea a few times it could work it could
work Chris they got hairy fighting
deathy yeah what what is this place good
point Chris where even are we right now
oh chz appreciate you it's all good
dude thank you thank you so much thank
you so
much much obliged wait that was the and
that was the second
guy mission complete all
right all right there we go now it's
time for the ruins this is the final
little
mini
side mission whatever you want to call
it of this
area har kills hundreds of dead theaters
in this
game I think for the trophy what was it
chat for those of you who were here at
the beginning was it 2,000 or something
we have to
get there's so many kills we have to get
in this
game and we already got I think we
popped a trophy earlier for 100 enemies
already
yeah it's just like like so far the game
is really it's really
mindless is how I would describe it I
mean the good side of that is like it's
really easy to keep up with chat a
thousand okay there we go it's real easy
to keep up with chat because there's
really not a lot going on here it's not
too crazy challenging or difficult even
on hard
mode
the part that's going to be annoying is
if we do go for the Platinum which you
guys already know I'm going to I'm going
to have to at least make the attempt at
it then I'm going to have to go back and
get all the Collectibles which I'm
assuming they do not stack I'd be
shocked if they
did probably going to have to collect
them hey reach level six going to have
to collect them on my easy
run
is when I think we go after
them n deserve much better than those
movies wait are you a good person right
there oh wait now I've got some help
okay it's not just me fighting
him
I think we just have to hold them off
right we're not actually rescuing
rescuing anybody in this
one the camera is getting worse and
worse too like when you're moving in a
certain direction it's like it won't let
me also turn the
camera maybe I do need to turn the
sensitivity back oh that's the problem
impediment oh wait you guys are with me
sorry how do I
tell there we
go I want to lock on to wait where'd he
go oh
impediment oh no they captured
one what I didn't even know that could
happen this is just like a hoorde mode
basically we just have to defend the
area yeah exactly protect these
people mission fail wait did I
die I died right
[Music]
there I was just shocked because it
there was nothing like my screen didn't
start to go black or anything it just
you're just dead
still I'm trying to figure out a way to
use Prego
strategically
Pego but it
just I got a trophy for using it earlier
I think that's the only time I need
it didn't I just drink of blood
replenishing oh I bet the Spells do
let's try let's try petrificus we
haven't been able to hit anybody with
that
yet there we go and then switch
to I like impedimenta because I can hold
it and do
the the burst right there see how it
does like the burst fire
oh I think we I think we stopped
counting the deaths during the doxy
sequence I think we
did but that is a good question Jesse if
the Spells
do like what is this lady do like what
do you
help snap out of it okay we should just
can I use this cover right here nope how
about this
there we
go I don't think I'm hitting that
guy that's not a guy that's a
rock yeah let's drink
[__] even though I can't tell like I
have no idea what my health is I don't
know if my health refills after each
little phase or
not normally like when you're getting
weak it'll start the screen starts
turning
dark but that last time it did not it
just
completely how are they C where are they
even capturing you
at over here I
bet no okay this is not
good three
captured I just thre doxy side at
them okay there's more doxy side
good
a
impediment controls are so bad right
now drink it drink it drink it drink
it oh where did you come from no no no
no no no no no please please please
please please don't end
it fun with
you oh wait you guys are good aren't you
you're trying to help
me
it's
okay these are the final two I have to
protect them right
here no no no no no no no no
no dude why is the camera not
turning sometimes it just
stops it just stops
[Music]
moving one more left maybe one more one
more where are you
where are
you grab the little Beggars oh you can
come easy or
painful where is this
guy is that him there he is did I walk
by you like five times
mission
complete okay there we go my
goodness my health problem will be
solved in hard mode I I don't know what
do you mean by
that that it will be
solved with Ron and Hermione's
reconnaissance complete the trio attempt
to ENT enter the ministry of magic
unseen yeah they uh back to Hogwarts Day
last year they announced they were
working on a documentary for Hogwarts
Legacy and then said it was going to
release last year and it just went
silent ever since we haven't heard
anything the entrance to the ministr I
feel like this week would be a great
week for it it's through there on the
main road one year anniversary there
bound to be a garden we can't aerate in
but we can't just walk in they'd
recognize us the H Crux is in there we
have to find a way
in well then we'll have to find a way to
disguise
ourselves oh no we going to have
to I knew it follow regge cmol and
attempt to subdue him without being
discovered there's old
regge wait this is him right okay and we
have to and you Stupify to stun them
well I got to wait till he's away from
people don't
I if we did it right here maybe he's
going to go
into okay right let's do right here
impediment what re no
re
no I thought we just had to hit him one
time wait how's it not triggered how
have we not failed the mission
yet how have we not failed the mission
what is
happening why is it even doing
this yeah just just take me out I'm so
confused
yeah that rumored Lego remake I think
that I think somebody made that up
sadly but if anything it should show
them oh maybe we should do
this I guess I just didn't wait for him
to I must just need to follow him a
little bit
longer get close to your Target and you
Stupify to stun them that's what we did
but yeah that that's what I that's what
I did do okay now impediment oh I'm on
the it was on the wrong
spell
got to be kidding me oh look at
this see I would assume that the game
would put you on the correct spell since
that's the one that you need to use in
that situation but
no
nope all right so now do we need to look
for the next person probably but I bet
we need to get back to the group
first report back say we we' got one oh
now we need to follow
mafala mafer hop
cook make sure we're on the right
spell we have to get
I have enough dudee is she going to go I
mean there's so many people
around okay now oh no there's a person
right
there can you leave
lady
what
no I'm stunning her why
no so wait then do you just lose why
doesn't it reset me
though oh another Potter watch
shoot how does it not just instantly
fail the
mission and why we were on the right
spell were we
not dude this is so confusing oh there
she is she's
back she comes back even though somebody
was trying to stun her she's like it's
okay I still got to get to work
so I think that lady threw everything
off now there's a dude right
there what is going on man
what why is she not being
stunned
I'm really
confused now she's going to reappear
over
here she's back let's
go okay we are on
Stupify maybe it has to be like directly
to her back while we're still under the
cloak while no one else is
around I mean
that's that's all I got
man wait a little bit longer Anonymous
thank you I will try
it appreciate the tip let's
see now my my what's about to run run
out no
no there we
go okay Nobody's
around oh
now I think it I think it's the nobody
around
thing that must be
it excuse me sir excuse
me Albert runcorn
that's
right this is this was one of the better
scenes in the movie I gotta
say the polyu scene those actors did
such a good
job of playing like a person posing as
them especially Bellatrix man Hermione
is
Bellatrix so
good but even like fala the lady who
played her really sticks out of my mind
too look at this lady like right beside
him right beside
him I think that's where he's going to
stay okay let's try
it all right grab it grab it cloak back
on let's go oh my
goodness did we already get this one oh
no that's not a thought that was a
collectible
shees always freaks me
out oh here we go at least I didn't end
up with eyebrows like that Harry better
get to the entrance before the poly
potion wears off and Ron please don't
call Harry har when we're inside this is
completely mental completely utterly
without
question I'm actually kind of looking
forward to this part I want to see how
they what they do in the game I mean we
know it's going to somehow end up
being a shooting battle we know that get
the work done dangerous times dangerous
times uh
yeah where we supposed to go right here
right here right
here at least we don't have to hide
now yeah M door I thought that sounded
like him I will never
way Alicia back
again welcome
back we're making good progress so far
guys we were a little bit late getting
started because of the update we had to
do on the
game took a little bit longer than I
expected oh my
goodness some creepy looking Death
Eaters right
there we flush ourselves in apparently
so that's Bloody Disgusting just pull
the chain so it better be a magical
[Music]
to
blim me there are enough death
ear I fancy being spotted by this lot oh
you already know you already
know get to the lifts uh
yeah okay this is kind of cool though
getting to see the ministry alone here
don't look
nervous wait I think I see something
yeah there it is
someone
experiment let's get to the lifts we
should go to the vs I'm going you
guys just want to take in the sights for
a little
bit if you guys haven't seen at you can
check out one of my most recent videos
about
the ministry of magic section that is
coming to The Wizarding World in Orlando
I cannot wait to see
this I cannot wait it's going to look so
amazing personally I'm going to put all
my valuables into
green hey Archie the pair I've been
looking welcome in thank you for the
your I would have thought you'd make an
effort to turn up to meetings hope
you're having a good day so far my wife
for gotten her already well you'll have
to after she's sentenced now come along
or do you want me to report you too of
course he doesn't we'll both
come sorry mate we'll find you when we
can you find Umbridge she's on level one
Ron you get down there and help Mary
come on
now go to the security office to find
out which lift goes to level one oh my
goodness I didn't mean to
shoot guys I didn't mean
it
I I didn't mean it please don't shoot me
that was my
bad that was my
bad oh my goodness I kind of love that
it doesn't end the mission
though that's pretty cool now I'm
curious if I could just go crazy though
and wipe out everybody in here if I
started
firing act natural act natural
everybody I can't even walk fast like
can we not even jog a little bit oh my
goodness it's worn off
no that's that was a quick poly juice
are you kidding me
that was really really
quick what am I doing search the
security
office
wait okay don't mind me excuse me excuse
me okay okay we're good we're good we're
good we're still good but even this is
going to wear off
soon the middle lift will take you to
level one okay so that's all I needed
right now we can go
back hary hearing hairy
breathing oh no turn to the lifts okay
go go go go go go go we need to get in
here then we can take it off for a
second okay take it off for a bit and
back
on I think they're shooting at me me I
don't know how but I think I heard
someone shooting at
me oh yeah this dude like how I had my I
had my uh I was in that
Hall I'm at the lifts why are the lifts
not
opening why are they not
opening oh my goodness
finally
[Music]
jeez casting fundo can turn enemies
against each
other we don't have that unlocked
yet search for Umbridge on level
one I've heard that hot warts is in for
changes there are so many changes every
day I I'd really rather not
but us invisibility cloak sneak past
people
or does not give you time to
read TOA Potter still on the Lo
why am I feeling so tense right
now
oh I'm just not here search your
office excuse me don't mind me oh we're
in her office we're in our
office
nice unlocked
expulso search the other offices for
clues about where Umbridge you got to be
kidding
me I mean she really doesn't have that
much in
here okay so we got expulso
now
nice that's not creepy at
all
why are they just standing right
there where is my point
me what Harry you don't need to you
don't need to remove the cloak search
the other office okay here we
go dude they're all just standing around
with the wands drawn too whoa excuse
me we have to search six
offices get out of here with
that not to mention the cloak runs
out okay here we go here we go here we
go
did this count did it give us give it to
us I was too busy worried about the
potion oh excuse me sir no it's like
knew where I was man okay three nice
that one did count all right let's take
this off for a
second and here we
go you never completed this
one you played it back on the Xbox 360
Grim this is my first time ever playing
it boy it is it is
something oh back
up let's see do we need to go left or
right I'm just going to guess
right
oh maybe I guessed
wrong hold on did we do this
one no we did
not another potterat password let's
go there are way more Collectibles than
I
thought
no hold on we need to take this off for
a
second there we
go where are you pointing me oh right
there right there right there oh my
goodness five out of
six no
is please don't no don't tell me we got
to do all of them
again please I'm not looking at chat I
don't want to
know oh my goodness I just did see Marco
though Marco coming in with another $
Marco
dude thank you so much man I think it is
nice content keep it up Marco too kind
of you my friend too kind appreciate
that man hope you're having a good day
so
far that is a very very generous
donation seriously dude appreciate it so
much I'm glad you've been enjoying the
content despite the fact that the game
itself is really it's it's an
interesting
one I'll put it
nicely okay the good news though is that
it did not make us have to go back and
find all of them again find Umbridge in
the
courtrooms now we just have to go
directly to
Umbridge it's all a matter of good you
have to have the right people in the
right
places
experiment nice back to the lifts let's
go okay we did it we did it guys I
thought it was really going to make us
reset everything right
there that would have been very
unfortunate very very
unfortunate gaming Arc how's it going
Harry Potter shooter yeah call a Potter
as I've heard it referred to many
times
okay oh this part's going to be kind of
crazy though
right
let's see if they actually have the
Dementors and everything on our way
out wait where was
that did it turn me
around oh right
here hello sir hello there
why do you all look the same you snatch
us you all look the
[Music]
same okay wait a
second uh let's go right here maybe no
no no like right right in this
corner cloak back
on
hello
sir I'm just guessing is this the right
way I don't think it is no this
way be one with the wall be one with the
wall
oh here we go is this it let's go we did
it would all SN es the accused to the
court area immediately you heard what
she said get
[Music]
moving we're still not down
there
hor horo horo thank you for subscribing
welcome in welcome
in can I get by this dude just don't
just pretend I'm not here it actually
worked it actually
worked I don't even know if this is the
way we're supposed to go
but nope it
wasn't CU of course not
come on man you got to hurry wait is
that
Arthur
no oh no we're
dead we are so
dead they're like he
vanished it's like
Batman come
on I need you to move sir sir I need you
to
move look at them
all oh my gosh what is this game man
okay wait let's try it maybe we can do
uh Harry cloak cloak my
man
[Music]
this is where we're supposed to go I
heard he went that
way yeah over there go check it
out nope he's not there he's that
way nope nope yeah yeah through through
there through the archway sir go
on yes that you're you're on the right
TR yes there you go thank you
now you sir yeah you're fine right
there they're not very
smart they're not very smart
guys I don't see where the the point me
is going so that might be a bad sign
yeah that means we need to go back we
took a wrong or we didn't take this turn
right here oh my
goodness don't mind me we're almost
there I can sense it I can sense it
we're almost
there what the
heck oh that's not right
man bro I didn't know they were going to
break out the
dors
ah we
almost we almost pulled it
off we almost pulled it
off even though we completely botched
that okay yeah through here this is
where we got seen right in this
spot oh wait you really I was about to
say are you really going to stand right
there I'm just going I'm just going I'm
just going I'm just
going no that's not fair please
walk
I feel like I can't talk either when I'm
doing
this feel like we we just have to be one
with the cloak right now guys he won
with the
cloak we're almost there I know we
were now see the problem is the
Dementors they don't care about this
invisibility cloak the court is ready
to well I think we're all ready to
continue now but it looks like the game
doesn't know that so we're just going on
in just going on
[Music]
in yes yes we shall have to investigate
whether he too is a muggleborn imposter
working at the heart of the ministry and
helping other muggleborn infiltrate his
Department you just supposed to listen
to this pure wisting blood you are mudle
born admited Mrs cat
Stone I mean in the movie Harry's just
like yo here I am all right Dolores you
ready for this I'm going to hit Dolores
with an
expulso oh my goodness Dolores is strong
Dolores is
strong theor got those powerful dark
spells man look at
that oh no wait is she gone yeah get out
of here
[Music]
Dolores impediment
impediment or Patronis is freaking me
out I don't know if I can if it's going
to attack me or
what oh is she
back
like the combat would have been so
improved if they would have just given
you a Dodge man if I could just roll
left roll
right you're just constantly like a
Sitting Duck unless you want to hold
[Music]
that Dolores quit sending your henchmen
to Do Your Dirty
Work
oh my goodness another wave you got to
be kidding
[Music]
me guys I don't know if I can play this
game three
times I'm saying it right
now Le your
[Music]
lesson for those of you who are just
joining in thinking why would he
possibly want to play it three times see
you survive a DeMent three playthroughs
required if you want the platinum trophy
required I know I
know hurry expect
Oona we heard there was trouble collect
the locket all right where is it
you Patron
them
patronum nice okay lock
it new spell unlocked confundo press and
hold L2 to aim then press R2 pass spell
I don't think we're going to use that
right now oh there's a lock let's go the
door's open get out of here flu Network
in the atrium it's the only way out of
the
ministry all right let's go
is this as fast as you can run
Harry no
way s spells to match
situations this kind of an awkward
positioning right here feel like they
want me to use
confundo since we just learned that
one wait
whoa oh this is the sniper one this is
the SN it's like why is it zooming in
like
this what is the camera right
now Hermione get out of the way we're
going to snipe this
lady I can't aim at the head though it
it's just
like
what is this why is this lady still
[Music]
here I I think they're just fighting I
don't know what's going on I'm just
going to leave I'm just going to get out
of
here hi
oh no no no take cover Harry take cover
please thank
you all right let's look for that one
that's the
sniper oh got
him oh wait it just stuns them it looks
like yeah stuns him for a
bit you chose the wrong
side confusion Reigns oh no wait is that
the one that makes them fight against
that's what it is they fight against
each
other missed
him
oh he dodged
it it even makes us sound like a sniper
man there we go now he starts look look
look he starts helping
us
yes that's why I couldn't hurt that lady
earlier in the hallway oh wait you turn
on me
now
could hold on hold on hold on I got to
get my sniper out Hermione
come on Harry you got to get a better
shot than that what do you
think oh yeah so we can't hurt him at
all while he's under
confundus but then he breaks free all
right we got it we got it we got it now
that's Neo oh my
goodness Crouch okay we need we need our
sniper
boom
yeah I know you're about to break
[Music]
free what does Felix Ficus do in this
game makes my spells more powerful or
something CH the WR
side oh great we got Dementors
[Music]
approaching the controls for the
Patronis charm are horrible by the way I
just want to say if if I ever look
awkward while I'm casting it you guys
know why but then again pretty much
everything in this game looks awkward
and like it's not working
properly you have to tap
L1 wait wait wait first you have to be
close them you can't cast it from afar
because no range for Patronis charm
obviously and then you have to uh tap
L1 and then press and hold
L1 so it's like tap and then press it
again but hold
it it's very
strange hey we'll need to get to the I
don't I'm not intent wait
where's wait Ron is still regge isn't
he go
Patron and we don't even get to see this
stack like come on after all this
trouble come on where's the Stag for
us Alexis welcome
in also
stins yeah the later games this is my
first time ever playing this one I've
obviously heard a great deal about it
and how I never needed to play
it but here we are for your viewing
pleasure chat for your
amusement we're playing on on hard mode
by the way too
guys Harry Potter in the Deathly Hallows
part one hard mode because if I ever do
want to go for the platinum trophy we
got to beat it not once not twice but
three
times okay
which
way oh my goodness you guys hiding out
back
here no no no drink the spell drink the
potion okay good A little bit of a
checkpoint right there I was afraid that
it was going to put us back very
farive
actually was back further than I
thought oh man we're getting hit a lot
this time yikes okay all right you know
what it's time for the sniper it it's we
we got to break it out right
here Harry Potter get your sniper my
friend
confundo locked and loaded right in the
head
yeah you sir oh we missed him
it's all right maybe we can do an
expulso
now man expulso is kind of trash isn't
it it's not even doing
anything okay hold on I got to figure
this out before we go to the next
section you hold it down
gotcha Patron them
okay so it's it's like
a like a rapid
fire oh my goodness dude this is so
hilarious IM Mouse yeah I've heard I've
heard people say that part two is is
improved so we'll probably be playing
this one obviously today and then I
think I don't think we'll finish it
today I'm yeah won't finish it
today okay there's expulso all right all
right all right so yeah we'll probably
be playing this one again next week and
then after that we'll move to part
two the ministry of fights all right all
right so now that I actually get how to
use expulso it's not too
bad I really don't I wish the camera was
better the ministry of
Fikes
okay we're coming up to that hallway
where you got two oh yeah this
guy all right
no oh no they're behind me
again come on just get in there yeah
just get in oh we were right at the end
are you serious we were that close to
the end when we died earlier
expulsive Stormtrooper
blast beat by Fred does Daniel Radcliffe
uh Daniel Radcliff does not but that I I
can feel it it's like the HW Crux is
alive we should take turns to car that
is rert the sooner we can find a way to
destroy it the better and that Emma
sounds pretty close what should we do we
have to get out of here quickly but I I
don't think it's her I don't think it's
actually
Emma
there are a few that are the actual
voices though from
the I still think I might like
impedimenta
better but it is nice just being able to
hold it down for a little bit we can't
beat them we can't beat them oh so you
want me just to leave all right
fine is this where we're supposed to go
nope this way oh yeah we got to get to
the
flu whoa I didn't know there was a guy
right
there okay hold on you know what time it
is sniper time you guys
whoa nice help me
sir it's the sound effect man that just
cracks me
up I'm running I'm running I better get
actually hold on let's take cover
here no where is it where is it where is
it
no this part's kind of crazy not going
to lie there's stuff going on
everywhere can I turn you to help
me take
that
oh you can no way that's
funny yeah come on over you lead the way
sir all right he broke fre of
it here's what we're going to
do use confundo from over
here oh we missed all right let's run
let's run let's
run this guy's on our side right
now now he's
not no no no no no not like this take
cover please take
cover
Harry oh my
goodness there we
go take
all right we got two working for us
now hey it didn't hurt to
try where are we even supposed to go
right now just to the end of the hall I
guess oh we made
[Music]
it too late mate
yeah that section was a little
nuts cast Proto to stop or deflect enemy
spells you recover health switch okay so
you do recover health all right switch
spells select potions a difficult case
another trophy
obtained we're probably about halfway
through this game cuz it's it's a very
short game from what I understand
especially if you're only doing story
stuff lie
still where are we I thought we were
going to Grim old place we were but a
death he to grabbed Ron I had to change
where we were going but I did it so fast
I must have made a
mistake now Ron's
hurt oh right splinched lie still I need
to apply some disy
it'll hurt less if you stop moving it
will hurt less if you stop poking
me how do we know they won't find us
here vder no don't say it I've heard
someone in the ministry they've made you
know his name Tabo if you say his name
they can find
you and that's that must be how they
found us at the cafe herione be
quiet I can hear
someone we're going to walk into
snatches if we keep going like
this that sounds like Dean
Thomas oh yeah I see you guys letting
uh and by the way let me know if I'm
mispronouncing that hiding from death
and yeah lots of Hogwarts Legacy content
here on the
channel actually working on a working on
another another Hogwarts Legacy video
here actually going to have two more
Hogwarts Legacy videos this month
all right follow Dean Thomas cast Four
Points this actually speaking of
Hogwarts like I see this looks like a
little section out of it like a little
ruins area all right I need an open area
after that whole Ministry section sheesh
man inventory full
Okay Okay so we've got what is this
spell or this potion even
do so it like makes them choke or
something all right I mean cuz we could
be using these in these really tough
battle scenes I only have four of these
but does that one does the darkness
powder let
me kind of vanish break their tracking
or
something dbdh exactly must have been
quite stately in its
time I know what this is Merlin
trial follow Dean Thomas yeah I know
we're just exploring a little bit game
relax we found some extra potions back
there as a result of
it yeah it was like they they had a tall
order because they couldn't rely on
Hogwarts you know they knew this had to
be a different typ of G you doing with a
goblin gri her grip her keep your voice
down or you want to get
caught they knew they had to make a
different type of game but then they
also were under you know pretty big time
crunch cuz like you can see they had
they had some good ideas they they knew
it had to be more of a combat Oh I
thought that was Dean what in the
world
Ron watch
out like if they would have had more
time to fully flesh out the spell
system like just just imagine if it was
the exact same Mission structure and
everything but with the controls and
spells of Hogwarts Legacy it would still
be not a good game
dire
but that alone would have really
improved
it oh no I want I want confundo oh not
not confundo the uh expulso yeah yeah
feel like that'd be really good on
these oh my goodness they're actually
exploding
actually it's really not that good is
it I didn't mean to throw another one
okay so you do have to hit them with the
potion then it does tear through them
pretty
quickly oh now we got spiders
too what's next a basilisk here at the
end we've had dragons
we've had a dragon already we've had
spiders we've had the
doxies it's like which way are we even
supposed to go right
now I love how right in the middle of
battle if you walk up close to ronner or
minione it still gives you the option to
talk because now is a great time for us
to ask questions don't you think hold on
I want to see what's over here if
there's
[Music]
any any secret or
anything your spells are now more
powerful let's
[Music]
go yeah Roger I think that was uh I
think that was incorrect
it was like gaming Bible or something
right and then when you go and read the
article all they're doing is quoting the
uh if you look at the official hogw pacy
tweet it sounds like later this summer
is when it's when it's coming unless
they change something like since I've
been streaming
today
take that
you yeah the music's not too
bad hydrate oh yeah I've been I've been
sipping here throughout the
stream got my Coke Zero
there okay I'm going to
guess I was going to guess that way that
would have been
wrong
yeah the music's one of the few things
that's actually pretty solid in this
game it sounds like they're alone this
would be right right around the point
where he got bored and shut the game off
I can't imagine
why can't imagine why you would have
gotten
bored no I def def get it I definitely
get
it but seriously guys appreciate you
hanging out and helping me get through
this I knew this was a game that like
dude I'd be bored out of my mind if I
was playing this off a Goin Death Eaters
don't like anyone who's not human maybe
they're both dodging Death
Eaters playing this off stream would
have been horrible so thank you guys for
being here and keeping me company and
appreciate the new Subs as well if you
guys are watching and haven't yet subed
to the channel
if you're into all things Wizarding
World then this is definitely a place
where you would want to subscribe WE
Post news theories
discussion all about the Wizarding World
of Harry Potter we focus on the video
games but we've also been covering uh
the theme park news the the Harry Potter
reboot the TV show we're going to be
covering that as
well all
right inventory full yeah that little
caring grass or
whatever let's let's just try it let's
try it in battle right
here yo okay
okay wait where was it it is left on the
d-pad okay so it's not I thought it was
an instant but you do have to do a few
spells in combination with
it are you feeling all right no Ron I
wasn't talking to you I was trying to
pick up the man the spell right
here nice horo thank you appreciate
that yeah Roger I saw that too cuz I get
I get alerts to my email anytime there's
uh I think I have them set up for once a
week where Google will basically send me
any mention of Hogwarts
Legacy I I'll get sent that and so I saw
that pop through last night and I was
like
what and then I actually read it and
they just repeat what's in the Tweet I'm
like okay you might want to change your
headline then unless they know something
we don't which I've I've kind of
followed that site before they're very
heavy on the rumors and speculation they
they post a lot of
that so if you're waiting on Haunted
Hogs me for PC and Xbox possibly switch
we don't know for
sure Hogwarts Legacy says later this
summer dude they got to do something
this week though man it's the oneye
anniversary I I still hope that the
documentary comes out and I don't know
like I know I don't want you guys think
I have some inside I have zero inside
info on this
whatsoever but it just feels right
doesn't it like I feel
like what did that just backfire oh this
guy shot
me it feels like it would be such a good
time for it the oneyear anniversary if
you guys didn't know about this they
last year on uh September 1st back to
Hogwarts
day they they said that they were going
to uh put out this documentary they
released a trailer for it and everything
the making of hogwart's
legacy and said later this year which
was
2023 and it never
happened so maybe they just didn't get
it done in
time
impediment dude why are we
not there we
go this week would make so much sense I
don't know if they would release it
tomorrow though like the day of the
Early Access or if they they' probably
wait
till Friday the 10th but man it would be
such a great
announcement such a
fun such a fun thing for us on the Oney
year anniversary like I I'm honestly
like I've convinced myself it's
happening I don't want to get you guys
too hyped but in my mind I've convinced
myself it's happening again zero like no
inside information they haven't even
hinted at like they've not mentioned it
it could could be cancelled they could
have decided to stop doing it for all we
know but I feel like they would have let
us know
that but they've they've said nothing
whatsoever about it
so all right let's see where they want
us to go next they said why do they keep
appearing I think they're going to keep
appearing until I clear
out until I clear this out right
here there we go
they PR good at delays oh
man the weird the weird part to me is
that they didn't say anything like
that's what makes me in the back of my
mind I worry like did they just decide
to scrap
it it's it's not like a game it's not
like you need to let everybody know hey
this is not coming out anymore
but I feel like they I feel like they
need to say something pretty
soon just even if it's like guys it's
taking way longer than we
expected expect it later later this
year or honestly we don't know but we
still want to make it
happen impediment it's the lack of
anything that I think is uh most
bizarre what what is even happening like
where am I even supposed to be going
right
now I know we
just we just apparated away from the
ministry I I'm just yeah oh yeah Dean
that's right Dean and the
Goblin Dean and the Goblin I'm I'm just
done I'm not going to fight you guys we
may not get the trophy we need but I
just I thought it said defeat the wiing
Willows Dodge theing Willows dude we
didn't say wiing Willows we've seen
spiders now we've had
Dementors we've had doxies now it's time
for the wiing Willows ladies and
gentlemen don't mind
me insta death insta death yeah don't
mind
me oh there's more
great multiple wiing Willows here in
this random
Forest like what dude what is going
on they're just like okay what can we
pull from lore we got to have more
enemies for them to fight here let's put
up a few of those
trees what is it the wiing Willows oh
there's only supposed to be a few of no
no no we're we're putting some more here
the one it's in Hogwart no no no we're
going to put them in this Forest it's
just going to be in this random area
better when we know what we're doing now
you know what would be hilarious if like
we never see them again in the game it's
like if it was just if it was for that
one
section what happened when me left
Ministry us away from G oh my goodness
they know were there is there only one
wiing Willow no right we had to escape
you did what you needed to do there are
more than one wiing Willow we know about
like one in the series but apparently
they're if I remember right they're
pretty rare uh and the one the one at
Hogwarts is significant because it
wasn't planted until like
after oh jeez what would the time period
have been when it had to be
planted like
after James and him were there if I
remember
right wait did we just get sniped from
somewhere
[Music]
defeated 250
enemies let's
go 25% there right you guys said a
th000 that's right yeah yeah yeah with
looping with
looping
there you
go because he was uh transforming into a
werewolf for
protection but yeah it is technically
like a type of tree that exists in the
magical world I made a video about this
in the leadup to hogwart's Legacy
because we all thought that looked like
a wamp and Willow on
the on the artwork for the game which I
still say it did
and I still say that it I think it might
have been in their original plans to
have that be aing
Willow but yeah it would it couldn't be
the wiing willow we know from the
series cuz that one wouldn't have been
planted yet for legacy's
time all right there's a potion over
there
yeah kind of like
a oh is it is it really a creature like
a mandre not
Enchanted I yeah I think it's actually
like a creature but it's
not I don't think it appears in
fantastic Beast so it's not like a beast
either this way okay hello
sir
I love how they just keep appearing in
random spots like right in front of me
whoever said the last of us this does
kind of give me some Last of Us Vibes
this area that we're
at and the controls are
just man it's rough the camera more than
anything yeah that's right I need to
keep using those
potions yeah who would have thought doxy
side makes the doxies much easier to
deal with guys it's like whenever you're
in close quarters the game struggle the
camera really struggles with
positioning yeah that's a great question
of where where are we apparently we're
trying to chase down Dean and a goblin
oh that one's
stuck there we go
oh sorry Hermione I thought it was now
where Point
me show me the
way I love how every game they had to
come up with a new like
traversal mechanism for
you in year five they use the Marauders
map then they use Nick for year
six this game they're like let's give
them the point me spell oh my
goodness where did that shot come
from up
there oh right there
too man I am getting so many more spam
calls
lately I don't know if something changed
during at the new year like I'm on all
the Do Not Call List and stuff that you
can sign up for
and it was getting really good like I
hardly ever got any now I'm getting them
all the time again I wonder if something
changed in 2024 that
has made them start up again all right
this way I just since I've been sitting
here I've gotten
two I know I thought that completely
took me
out oh I didn't mean to throw
that
impim I mean it kind of worked though it
hurt me but they're all still doubled
over choking health is
increased I'll happily take
that strengthening solution I wonder
what
woo did that hit him did that actually
hit him I don't think it did it was just
short okay this mission is
bad I think we've said that about every
Mission but
uh please Dean like does Dean not hear
all this
fighting come to us Dean where you at my
man
ooh a
collectible
okay Ron what are you doing man come
on what's he doing over
there oh
finally sheesh I don't know how much
more of that I was I would have been
able to take
the forest is full of magical creatures
you guys ready to trap The unary
Traveler I don't know if you guys forgot
that part in Deathly Hallows all the
magical creatures that attack them in
the forest har poter that is all you
Wizards talk about yet from what it says
in the daily profit he's not much of a
thing to put your faith in you can't
believe anything you read in the prophet
you should try the
quier are
yeah bush bush
logger same I don't know why it started
happening a lot more are we supposed to
be like follow them quietly
or who are these
guys who who is this dude death
they're they're gone now all
right Dean it's me dude oh no wait
that's not Dean that's not Dean we're
still not Dean is like they keep showing
us Dean in the cut scene and then he's
gone all right you know what let's try
this I just want to see if this works
Stupify oh it actually did let's go
stealth
mode should be using that more
often follow Dean Thomas cast Four
Points in
Fury what is happening dud they cannot
be defeated but you can stun
them oh my God goodness
man don't you guys remember all the
inferia that show
up just in this random muggle swamp not
swamp what would you call this like
a i a rock Corey I mean where the heck
are
we as horo said
earlier I mean do we just keep spamming
until something happens
yeah I get I get they can't be defeated
do we just
leave oh there's more over here
great Point me please
[Applause]
work okay wait that way all
right back you Savages
oh tap X to get out of an infurious
[Applause]
grasp you can just see the pitch meeting
when they were making this game they're
like
okay zombies are super popular right now
in gaming you guys Harry Potter if you
all didn't know they they have some
zombie like we got to get those zombies
in the
game do they do they run into the
zombies in the books no no no no no not
not at this part we we we saw them at
the end of the last book though and
there were a lot of them and the the
people really loved them we got to put
them in the game well do they do they
run into them in the in the movie that
the game is based no they don't run into
them there but I'm telling you
zombies zombies you guys we we got to
have them in this game's going to be a a
big time seller if we put the zombies
in we got to put the
zombies do we should we be worried about
like the lore like what fans will say no
no no no we don't need to worry about
that they just they love these creatures
they love the fans love fighting in Fury
this is what they need this is what they
want they're not worried about the book
accuracy they're not worried about that
they just want to fight these
things okay so are we going to give them
a fire spell so they can actually take
them out no no no I think I think we
should just have them only have the
ability
to stun them they can't defeat the
inferior they just they just have to
run that's all they can
do they just have to stun them and
run all right Bob I think we I think you
nailed it Bob we put that in Bob we're
putting that in Bob you know what I like
that idea so much you're getting a race
Bob in fact we're going to promote you
to the head of development
for the next
game oh my goodness you
guys I'm sorry I I have to I have to
make some kind of jokes to keep to keep
from going insane here we we got to we
got to stick with something here
man oh wait they're back dude they're
back Bob you're back with another
idea you know what's better than one INF
Fury in
section in section what am I talking
about here
section what's better than one in theory
section is two in theory sections man
it's two of them we need to have them
run into it again okay this time though
we got to give him a a spell right we we
got to give him a fire spell incendio
it's pretty basic spell it's been in a
lot of the games I think now is the time
for them to learn it
right no no no one no no incendio no
incendio they just they're just going to
have to keep stunning and keep running
through this
section I wonder if INF Fury count
towards the trophy of
uh I think you have to fight like every
type of enemy or something but if you
can't kill them maybe you can never get
that
trophy oh come on give us incendio
please to Dean maybe he knows what's
happening at Hogwarts that Goblin might
recognize us it's too dangerous it's not
like we have any other plan is it dead
by daylight Wizarding World Edition hey
there is that rumor for a Harry Potter
horror game I don't know if you guys
have seen that
one I don't buy it though I don't buy
it i' tell I I what I think it is what I
think where the rumor came
from so I know I know very little
rolling library on Twitter is the one
who uh shared that with me that's like
where that rumor came from and roll
Library said who he has sources he he
does have connected sources I'm not
denying that and from a source he trust
he said that uh he heard that they're
working on a Harry Potter or maybe did
he say Harry Potter or Wizarding
World I think he said Wizarding World
horror
game and I don't see it what I think it
could be though is I think it could be a
Hogwarts Legacy as command
[Music]
DLC
similar to the mission structure and
setup of the Haunted Hogs me Quest
that's like
my if they're doing that I just can't
see them making a full game out of
it because the audience the Potter
audience is is too broad and if you want
to go that
Niche I just can't imagine you would do
a horor
game what I would play it I would check
it out even though I'm not like a horror
fan guys how how long has this section
been
going I feel like I've been here for
hours like
dude Dean Thomas my man can we not just
like call out to
him we've been looking for him this
whole
time my
goodness imagine this is the end of the
game I I just got to switch spells to
get some some type of
variety we got to switch it up
here follow Dean Thomas no wait that's
what we're supposed to be doing
we're supposed to be following Dean
[Applause]
Thomas where am I getting hit
from oh that's you Hermione you're
trying to help
okay
impediment about 15 to 20 minutes Mia
what's up I didn't see you drop in good
to see you hope you're having a good
day Justin a are you having fun
yet I'm trying to figure out where this
ranks for me right now if it's worse
than gobble of fire cuz I made that post
yesterday and I I shared a picture of
the game and said hey guys I'm playing
this
tomorrow I've heard it's the worst Harry
Potter
game and so about half the comments were
like nah gobl of fire is worse but it's
bad and so I'm trying trying to decide
where I where I
sit dude that is Hermione and that's
wrong who where where are we getting
shot
from I don't even I don't even see
anybody so I'm just going to oh was it
you up
here they're bad and for to for
different
reasons
yes give me all those
potions I mean this this just feels like
a game where they did the bare minimum
and I I'm always hesitant to to critique
the devs especially when it's a time
crunch situation because you
know they they had to get the game out
by the
movie and so what we ended up
playing is probably a game that if they
had had like the time say Avalanche did
to work on Hogwarts Legacy this would
have been like not even a beta version
of the game again this is me being
charitable giving them the benefit of
the doubt which I think is fair in this
situation I think it's fair given the
situation now if they had years to work
on it and this is what came out then you
got a different story obviously but but
yeah it's almost like what we're seeing
here is like their early early
idea and if they had had more time they
could have they could have improved it
so
much did that just say we uh unlocked
wingardium
levos I think we
did follow Dean Thomas cast Four
Points
deep breaths deep breaths Gears of wand
I haven't heard that one that's good
too yeah the whole the whole game is is
very offbrand
you think it went downhill after uh POA
now see Ultra Blue Jr I just finished
haet Prince and loved it I think I think
ha Prince is is better than prisoner
baban my personal take honestly Half
Blood Prince I'm still trying to decide
it might be my favorite Potter
game currently it's it's Chamber of
Secrets the GameCube PS2 Xbox
version and so that's why it's just so
sad to see them go from that like they
didn't even bring over the like they
didn't bring over anything about the way
that game
worked the Spells hey expell armis
though let's
go because the way you unlock spells in
this game is just by spamming on you
have that's it guys that's it hey and we
reached level 10 that's good for a
silver
trophy all
right oh you got to charge this one
up a expel
us let us Harry Potter into Call of Duty
JK rolling
okay I don't know how much oversight she
had back then on the games I mean I know
she was involved to an extent
but I can't see her being
uh I mean it was probably one of those
situations like they just they it had to
come out
and because they split it into two as
warrio said earlier because they split
the uh dude that you know what that's
what they should have done they should
have let the game devs they should have
let them wait and release one game when
part two came
out that would have given them more
time and then you can just release the
full story cuz only doing the story in
this game it's like five hours or
something like it's not
even this is a complete joke for the
price that I guess this would would have
been $60 when it came
out $50 maybe can't remember if games
had went up to 60 yet in the PS3 era or
not I think they
had they might have still been 50 at the
time but yeah 50 60 bucks for a 5H
hour but yeah imagine if they had given
them the full the full time before part
two came out which I know wasn't that
much longer
after part one if I remember right cuz
didn't they didn't they film it
together the different teams at EA each
get to make their own Harry Potter game
magika that is something I would like
love to know the full story I don't even
know who you would talk to like
who within either w or JK rowlings team
isn't the right I know sometimes we have
people from WB and Avalanche who check
out the streams if any of you out there
see
this email me retr andur atgmailcom I
would love to just like interview people
because it's so
fascinating because Magicka I don't know
if you've seen my complete history of
Harry Potter V games video like the
first the first game for philosopher
stone it was a completely different team
that made the PC version of the game it
was no wonder and then you had the
PlayStation version of the game
completely different team then they
started doing these
uh so yeah it would be like somebody at
EA somebody at
WB I don't know who you would have to
tell I feel like there would be so many
people who would have had to be involved
in that but I think it's it's really it
would be a fascinating story find a way
to get past this barrier this right
here oh no this over
here you paid full price for it just to
name no way every John sort of a little
bit of side
content like there are these little
Collectibles you can find and then we
did
these they I think they call them side
missions but they were required so I'm
like well that's not really a side
mission there were three of them and you
like they popped up in a chapter select
style and I got to pick the order that I
did them in yeah I don't really think
there's any like true side
quest okay you know what guys it's time
for the
sniper oh no that was it I was on it
confundo boom got
him wait was there only one
what right in the
belt confundo right to the Belt oh wait
if I hold down that's right I can this
is much better
selection Ron did you really just block
my xell
armis
I feel like we're about to die here
blood blood replenishing
please oh right in the
head oh he got back up no
way
we probably could Mia W you exchanged it
for cash as soon as you were
able I can't say that I blame
you James Bond night fire on PC
console yeah Justin name I watched that
video that Flander did it was great
chisto
witchit now he worked on the PC version
if I remember
correctly guys we are still in the in
the chasing Dean
level I just had to I just had to like
think and remind myself this is not a
new
level
we are still in the same
level no way
dude I do have to fully charge that one
up
hey sounds good Murphy appreciate you
stopping
by yeah guys if you're hanging out and
enjoy the stream and you haven't hit
that like button yet make sure you hit
the like button the little thumbs
up send that signal to YouTube that this
is the greatest Harry Potter stream of
all
time maybe not the greatest
game but a great stream and if you're
not yet subscribed and you enjoy the
Wizarding World of Harry Potter make
sure you subscribe before you head out
today we post weekly videos on all the
latest news theories discussion
lore focus on the uh confringo hello
hello we focus on the Potter video games
but we also have been covering the TV
show The theme
park lots of stuff in store for visiting
World fans this year all right
so I heard confringo I think it was
Christian gamer telling us earlier that
confringo is pretty
strong so we finally unlocked it return
oh I bet it's going to take down the
barrier okay okay okay okay
okay recycled levels yeah it's the it's
the same spot where we had the little
uh that mission
earlier
yes we are still on the dean
part
somehow all right collect exploding
potion I got
it Magicka wait what did Magicka say
greatest number of retro deaths in a
live stream oh my
gosh I mean we did stream some Elden
ring back when that game first came
out lately though I've only been
streaming Wizarding World
games where is the point
me here we go yeah we had quite a few
deaths in the Elden ring stream Liza P
we had some deaths in that one too I
think the Elden ring stream probably I
remember streaming uh my boss fight
against marget and I was way
underleveled oh my goodness dude I was
way underleveled and I know we at least
fought him
times I believe it
was oh look it's another wiing
Willow Run
hurry hey what are you supposed to do
sneak by I tried that earlier that
didn't
work
inventory full oh
dude Dean my man how far are
you why you can you guys sit down can
you stop most Wizards think goblins are
on you know whose side we take sides
this is a Wizards War and why
you here ringot is no longer under sole
Goblin control and I recognize no
Wizarding Master why are they getting
attacked either my renge that's the
other question I have Revenge Death
Eaters brought a sword seever a snake
wal in through like nothing's going
onor only the sword is a fake grindor
sword is Goblin mate this was a poor
copy it appears that there are some
things even Wizards don't
know I know a lot of every John that's
so
true come it's time for us to move on I
knew you like that Harry Potter so I
thought you'd want this
game a sweet little grandmother they
making that
mistake I could definitely see that
happening
okay all right I'm going to try to sneak
by this time yeah see he doesn't care
he's still going to still going to bash
you are we dead no way come on get away
from the
tree all right away from the
tree
Ron don't shoot me man is there just
one did he get him I think Ron got
him this is by far the longest Mission
we've had oh please sword it's Goblin M
please so so nothing damages it it only
takes in that which makes it stronger
Harry you destroyed one hraux right Tom
Riddle's Diary with the Basilisk Fang
when you stabed the Basilisk the sword
taken some of its venom so the sword the
sword can destroy H
cruxes but unless I've got it wrong
gyffin sword is a fake it's just like
the h cruxes no one knows where the real
sword is did you think we'd be finding a
HRS every other day you're supposed to
be the one with a plan oh here we go you
said we should do what dumbledor wanted
only dumbledor didn't tell you anything
did he take off the locket please
Ron like this if you hadn't been wearing
it yeah I would and so would you if you
were honest go home then if you're so
unhappy go home to Mommy just leave the
H
CRS go home to
Mommy Run
Stop you staying or
coming
I love how there was like zero build up
to this in the game just just
zero Hey welcome in thank you for the
new sub we better find somewhere to
Camp Natasha maybe is how you pronounce
it appreciate it back
are you allowed to stream the actual
movie
nah
no I mean you could stream it but WB is
going to claim that and get the ad
revenue for you can like go online and
see uh like their clips and stuff from
the movies that people have online but R
come back we should do some okay find
somewhere to Camp let's see can we save
like does the game Auto save there's no
there's literally no save option so I
assume we've been Auto saving we need to
be ready to find the
next if he does come
back all right so I think I'm going to
find the
campsite you guys need I need to have it
confirmed that there's an auto
safe because there is no way I can play
through this
again except when I'm going for the
platinum
trophy
all right where do we go Hermione this
way all right just double checking if
there was now you know we're probably we
got to fight some baddies right before
we can uh find a place to Camp it's not
going to be that simple you
guys it's not going to be as simple as
just walking to find our our place to
Camp oh we do have a wiing willow again
come on run
Harry oh spiders of course wiing Willow
and
spiders oh
just wipe them all out with a one shot I
love it Hermione nice thank
you this is confringo you
guys this is their version of
confringo it's just like a rocket
launcher it really does feel like they
took different guns and weapons from
Call of Duty Gears of War and they're
like okay how do we bring those over to
the game I I don't know how you dodged
that I don't I don't think you
can I told you it wasn't going to be
that easy to find the
camp who is oh there somebody behind me
still oh it's
youim see here's here's your minigun
right here
expulso watch watch watch or like
youro that mlap
Essence I thought I already got
you oh look where we're at guys is
around look where're at
man funny this place looks
familiar I I I feel like we've seen
this
recently oh no no no no
no
are we
good where did you come
from where
where where was that guy
man all all right where are we
camping oh my goodness if we run into if
if the infy pop back
out if the infer pop back out I'm about
to lose
it I feel like I feel like they're going
to bring him back I feel like the infer
are going to come
back cuz you know we're going to have to
pass through the same
spot we're going to have to go through
that same area
dude these guys with the mask they have
more armor or
something I kind of
like Let's do let's do confringo
again oh maybe not maybe not maybe
not I'm
dead I went out in the open too
much
Dean Dean is that what we're supposed to
be doing I think yeah I think they said
forget it with Dean after they found the
sword they didn't really need Dean they
just wanted to see why why is he
following that
Goblin
wait I'm all the way back at the bridge
[__] no
way if he comes back right when we get
to the campsite that is going to be so
funny if it just goes immediately into
that next
scene no Arachnophobia mode in this game
I take it how do we fail that so quick
excuse
me all right maybe we need to do oh my
goodness you scared me what are you
doing oh I'm going to I was going to eat
here in a second but thank
you this rag tour supplying me with
snacks here she wants this Marathon to
keep going but I don't know how much
longer I can hang with this I think we
might have to
uh eat some lunch here in a bit
yep get hit by the tree and then let's
fire
this there we
go oh now where did you guys come
from who's hitting me nothing should be
able to hit me right
now
bring oh no her
minying can we blast the
tree all right maybe if
I oh wait maybe that is what you do you
get him angry then he swings and then we
run
by nope that still doesn't
work Run please Harry run get away from
the tree get away from the
tree how are you still up
man
dude this was a breeze last time what
happened
stup why do you keep coming
back
yeah I can I can feel it man I can feel
it I'm starting I'm starting to hit that
point you know that point where we got
to step away for a
while
pediment we must find the campsite oh I
see you I see you a new Death Eater or
snatcher whatever you guys are
teleporting in up
there see I'm not even calling it by the
proper term
anymore I'm losing my Wizarding World
lore cuz I'm so frustrated heck the game
doesn't follow the lore why should
I why should I use the correct terms be
careful there are eaters
around Death Eaters what's next for miny
in
Fury
I can't wait man you know the infi
you're going to be there you know they
are dude you know they are those of you
who have played it do not tell
me I don't want to be spoiled on this
Gem of a
Game oh New spell unlocked press and
hold R2 to cast the spell and levitate
the targeted object release R2 to throw
the
object okay first I'm not even worried
about it though let's let's see uh I
want to see if I can destroy this right
here
actually oh you
can so is there a secret
here oh great oh great oh
great I sense us getting overwhelmed
Harry take cover
please okay yeah yeah yeah this is um
rough
situation I think what we need to do
here is we need to get one of them
fighting for us sniper right
there now let's just hit you with a
confringo that's our rocket
launcher now let's switch to something
like uh
impedimenta are we good are we
good we better be close to that campsite
man I can't take wandering in this area
for
another 30
minutes I just can't do
it oh just an aim if I go for the
Platinum you are
correct although I will just run through
cuz I'll be playing on easy mode and I
will just Sprint through this area like
if I was on
normal like do I even need yeah I don't
think you even need to fight these guys
I'm just doing it because you need to
take out a thousand of them for a a
trophy and plus because we're on hard I
think it might actually kill me if I
just tried to run through
impediment oh I knew there was one close
no no no no no please no
please
no no no not like
this why do they keep appearing behind
me I thought that was another
one the controls are so bad man they're
so bad they're so bad they're so
bad
go
down oh my goodness you
guys oh yeah here's the mentors right
before the inferior yeah come on come on
we were ready for
you our our petronis which is like a
giant orb now instead of a stag
Harry's own version of All Above Water
we can't
find all right where we supposed to go
herione where's the
campsite
where's oh we're supposed to destroy
this
okay I'll bring
what okay just walk by it got it got it
[Music]
please find the
campsite
secret
collectible
somewhere just a random
area fine then how about this secret
no all this is to
Camp yes the campsite right it's going
to be underneath the silos where we have
to first clear the
inury oh here we go you guys here we go
it's inury time you know it you know
it's coming where are they where are
they come on come on INF
Fury where are you I hear the
music
I will be shocked if they don't pop
out wait wait wait no
way oh my goodness Bob just wasn't able
to push that last that last INF Fury
appearance Bob wasn't able to get that
one
approved unless unless unless we're
coming back through we're coming back
through oh it says talk to
Hermione maybe we are going to Camp
right here maybe you weren't kidding
this looks like a good
place we could set up camp here I've
cast protective enchantments this looks
like a great place all this mud is
perfect but maybe Ron so good
back it's like the perfect place to Camp
hopeful for Ron's return Hermione stays
at Camp to research their next move
meanwhile Harry continues to search for
witches and wizards in in need of
assistance a friend from
afar all right complete the Encounters
in any
order but this feels like a good moment
to stop I just don't know how to
save the Corey I cannot do an area like
that right now Ministry deten yes please
just give me a different a different
scene all right I need somebody to
somebody's got to confir confirm to me
that there's an auto save please I can't
do this
again okay yeah I see the little Deathly
Hallow
symbol all right let me push start
there's no save
option we're just going to say quit any
unsaved progress will be
lost it's safe though right it's
saved chat tell me it's saved once you
reach a checkpoint oh my goodness thank
you Ki okay all right so yes I want to
quit oh yeah there we go continue
game oh my goodness all right ladies and
Gentlemen people of the
internet the new uh all the new Subs the
new members welcomeing guys thank you
for being here I'm definitely going to
need you to get through this one we'll
be back
again definitely next Tuesday
possibly m I was going to say possibly
before then but I don't know if I can
muster it up I don't know if I can
muster myself up to play again I don't
know I don't know if I
can this week anyway but we are going to
finish this game we're committed to it
I'm not committed to the Platinum just
yet I got to see how painful this is
throughout the whole process before I
decide whether I'm ready to take that
on but we will be back and we will beat
the
game at some
point guys thank you for being here hope
you all have a fantastic rest of your
day hope this gave you a smile at least
for part of your day hope you were able
to enjoy have some laughs with us
here and make sure you keep an eye on
the channel we got a at least one video
dropping this week appreciate all the
support guys as always thank you all so
much for watching I don't know why I
always Point like that you right there
I'll talk to you again
soon